allons il arrive quand je clique ici
lancé le red hot am est magique et
massive de normalement la bascule est
faite à fab alors la bascule est fait
mais de la bonne came as le marlou cas
mais pas très centré alors à temps alors
est-ce que c'est nous qui sommes pas
centrer ou pas je te dirai que j'ai je
pense que c'est un je pense que c'est le
caméraman envoyant aussi non attends je
vais faire un peu de technique déjà sur
la technique n y fit il la haye et la
ville j'aime bien ta confiance quand
même indéfectible juste mettre le
désirez et nous aussi
les nous aussi mais t'inquiète ça arrive
mais depuis guéri semir all blacks
combien de guiry pour arrêter un mvl à
ces questions que je posais jeu c'est
ben vrai patron répondu je j'ai eu des
tentatives est de réponse mais td dessus
non ça personne c'est trop une année qui
ont les 64 1 pour chaque case pas si
cons et voilà
on est là mais on s'est serré la main
alors là soit tu t'es qu'un choix qui
décale takam mais le ton à gauche à 4
alors allons y à l'échiquier aussi à
recadrer c'est pas possible et on va
être bon sa part pointe schennikov en
fait en tout cas ces deux cas il sait si
ce donc
donc c'est son ouverture du tournoi
notre ami guy et max qui fait des quatre
donc pas de rosso limo padroni mossad
renseignement et voilà donc va avoir un
petit petite explication théorique donc
maxime dit quand même
contrairement à l'epo à la ronde un lui
on lui a annoncé tiens je peux jouer ça
donc c'est clair qu'il a dû préparer
quelque chose et qui va il va quand même
tenté un petit truc presque pleine
ouverture gratuite est donc évidemment
je connais bien sûr que non en savoie
les similitudes
presse qui vont jouer vite c'est être
copier tout expliquer on va les laisser
en voyant les a en plus en grand la came
to sens on peut peut-être se délecter de
notre beau gosse à gauche en veste
costume bien assis sur sa chaise et y
rejoue les variantes avec eux prend des
5 eca renard et contre celle entre carl
scène en match une variante qui a pris
ce match et est venu vraiment à la mode
alors que c'était pas considérés comme
étant en fou mais c'est le choix de
l'ila et tout ce à quoi bon aller
deuxième connaît ça mais moi je connais
encore normes en gros on a direct d'une
structure asymétrique avec une majorité
de pions allèles dame pour les blancs
donc le plan pour les blancs on va se
développer d'abord mais c'est d'essayer
de réaliser b 4 c 5 et les noirs qui du
coup avons plutôt bien joué il faut
s'être petit rac et vont plus jouer à
l'est le roi avec la majorité ici donc
un peu une course comme ça qui se passe
stratégiquement c'est plutôt bien pour
les blancs mais dynamiquement les noirs
qu'ils vont jouer à droite plutôt
qu'autre héros adverses ça peut ça peut
faire peur donc faut être prêt et sousse
à quoi que tu penses que dans cette
ouverture grippe peut se tromper aller à
contresens contresens
guy ritchie à contre sens est ce que tu
penses qu'on a une chance d'un
contresens pour guérir d'un shifter pro
qui pourrait s'allumer côté mvl pour
passer la deuxième enfin dans ce tournoi
peut-être dire i
bah écoute fort qui se souvient de ses
analyses après gmail qui a dû réviser la
mv à lille joue pas une petite variante
du grenier mais un truc mainstream quoi
mon guy ritchie à contre sens ils sont
très heureux quoi le shifter frau pour
maxime sa période maximale c'est la
deuxième fois sur le prado
on est très heureux
je te croyais parti fin ça a
complètement coupé dans les matches qui
comme moi sont fous le mc le est déjà
plus nombreux que sur monsieur ça ne
fait que commencer
sans compter qu'ils ont tous les gens
qui passent sur chaise comme
internationale arrive automatiquement
fin ils ont déjà 4000 de base pas si fou
c'est assez impressionnant le nombre de
gens qui à quel point on est plus
nombreux ici
est ce que un coussin plus fort que geri
a oui le cce s quoi anfosso s est bon et
normal coûts de développement il veut
préparer son petit rock et on va voir
mais maxime écoute qui et c'est sûr que
là il a préparé quoi donc on va voir ce
qu'il arrive à presser ou pas on y
arrive
chante khairi concentré mais vous en
êtes sûr qu'il sera plus automatiquement
mais il essaie de se remémorer tout
comme il faut bien sûr bien sûr combien
de vior pour que guy peyrat tu penses
40000 way des fêtes de grille je pense
et 40000 joueurs et sinko bim force
assez inattendu peut-être je crois que
j'ai jamais vu à gears issue regarde la
sueur le géant sueur il ne se rappelle
pas et le joueur français qui s'en va
tout sourire un peu de chic et direct
avec le way en plus qu'avec la vase
prend la sueur côté le 73 mais si on
veut vraiment faut voir le 64 bits
enfin neuf ans si ça marche ça marche et
ça yogi qu'il serait interdit
monsieur l'arbitré n'a pas droit de se
lever quand ça nous jouer à mais ça y
est je suis déjà lancé des genres est à
dire c'est déjà fait un maquillage
chemise bleue dégueulasse mais ça c'est
interdit found se lever de sa chaise
quand ça joue et je comprends pas
comment on commence a réussi à passer
kayed se le faire double juste une fois
derrière henrik center 1 655 portée et
pas que par correspondance et pas que ok
bon jayavarman qui a joué ça c'est un
des seconds dans deux galeries d'art et
oui le fameux ouais donc normalement les
normes d'un croquis en fait
ok bon ben c'est pas une nouveauté mais
c'est une petite variante a pour le coup
est évidemment donc l'idée c'est que si
si les noirs prennent le pion bas et
maxime jouer des six attaques et
souhaité planter une fourchette tu peux
bouger les pièces at avec le four bon
bah si elle ne veut pas bouger le perdre
l'appui hâtivement de bouger je sais pas
on va dire si ce travail et bim
fourchette il se rappelle pas là donc
donc voila voila il se rappelle très
clairement pas un
donc c'est 5 il va falloir ne pas
prendre et a priori banquiers semble
semble logique quoi on arrive à prendre
[Rires]
ah oui c'est puis l'oubli sans issue et
en plus c'est maxime qui marche dans
leurs compétitions de marshall
ekatérinbourg la championnat de la
marche internationale d'ekaterinbourg
maxime prendre l'avant sur guéri je vois
que le plus grand marcheur une marque un
demi point bonus seraient exactement et
il ya une qualif pour les jeux
olympiques de tokyo siens sur le match
joué 50 morts le marathon marche
là on est sûr on a on a aussi fait
recette compétitions annexes comme très
importante avec un terrain bourg et
maxime là est en train de mettre la
pression sur son plus grand concurrent
guiry un marcheur un grand marcheur guy
aussi mais cloué sur sa chaise pour le
moment la ville a essayé de faire
quelques pas on n'en je déteste mais ça
n'a pas fonctionné
et là ils regardent maxime maxime qui
prend l'avantagé sur sa démarche est
assez des images terribles pour guéri
c'est diniz le second temps de maxime en
fait très très caché mais pourquoi diniz
l'accompagnent pas ekatérinbourg nam il
accompagne mais personne ne sait ils
sont dans la chambre d'hôtel il marche
quoi il parle genre d'hôtel ce qu'ils se
rappellent plus un c'est très clair mais
non on va priver rock et même si tu me
suis fait rien en fait oui mais mais ma
voiture devant lui tout seul
alors est-ce que c'est grâce à mon tweet
qui l'empêchait de réviser le verbal
quand il a pendant deux heures ils
étaient sur le tweet est ici que je
réponds je réponds pas j'efface abandon
en garde le cuir le dire d'une copie un
brouillon tout savoir après il laisse
transparaître beaucoup d'émotion quand
même c'est pas du tout comme dinghy hier
on ne voyait absolument rien sur son
visage la syrie est en sang la sueur
alors
une petite alerte figaro magazine le
monde
fabien la guerre en panique
le sel de guiry serait en train de
production de sel de jiri seraient
entrés en concurrence mais pas trop tôt
trop de stock ouais là guérande en
grande grande sur actuellement un dépôt
marche rendant le concours aussi fait le
sel de gironde
alors là je suis très heureux on regarde
la partie enfin moi je veux que voir
gear il en fait honte hurlements et
c'est très intéressant de le voir suez
n'ont rien il fut bien c'est pas en
regardant maxime en train de marcher que
tu vas trouver ton cou aniche s'est plus
concentré réflexion côté néerlandais
ah non là il est il est pas bien besoin
qu'il ose dire c'est bon déjà deux
doigts de la victoire
ouais qui peu beauf
non mais vous fera pas promis c'est
possible non c'est impossible qui bouffe
mais il va faire rock c'est sûr mais
c'est pas ce coup là c'est de se
rappeler plus tard c'est plus tard il
est où fermeture en vrai tu sais que
wardlaw traduit une inquiétude un ouais
ouais
boire beaucoup d'eau on part petit bourg
en jeu gorges et ça traduit une
inquiétude en body language si woods
tout ça c'est avec joueurs de poker ça
quelqu'un qui boit des petites gorgées
d'eau ça traduit une inquiétude soit tu
le sais toi tu le sais pas après
évidemment bombe serait quoi si tu vois
vraiment c'est que tu as soif mais quand
tu commences à avoir un tout petit peu
comme ça c'est que tu es inquiet cette
pause est rassurant sur sa avoir de
l'eau dans sa bouche ça rassure
technique pour citer en panique pour te
des paniques essaie de prendre une
gorgée d'eau la garder dans ta bouche ça
calme
tu peux essayer si tu veux mais tu as tu
as envie j'avais très calme ne vous
seront pas paniqué lui peu en panique
c'est parce que si
en bas il perd en fait il prend le pian
maxime pousse le sien at avec le fou qui
bouge pas en venir là et bim fourchette
attaque le roi attaque la tour et bien
gagné la tour du cou donc non ça va pas
se passer comme ça ça c'est bien mais
c'est pour ça qu'on pense qu'il vaut
bajus troqué histoire battre continue
son développement
a priori il ya peut-être un autre coup
possible c'est de faire à 6 mais je
trouve ça un peu soupçonnant parce qu'en
fait on donne le feu vert ou blanc pour
prendre et toute façon pour a priori
s'ils prennent énorme on prendra
peut-être en dessous donc je sais pas si
c'est pas une perte de temps après j'ai
jamais analysé la position donc je peux
pas dire exactement mais je vois mon
rocks damas logique échec promettent un
petit échec pour être un petit échec
il peut nous paraît l'échec j'imagine
oui si je prends le cari en v5
il est défendu un piège la tension est
sûre il ya quand même du venin mais
c'est venimeux c'est venimeux comme
position fab est guéri qui doit les voir
tous ces pièges pour son goût de l'eau
damas cinq dames prend b5
ah non pas de chance heureusement je les
ai vus vite me robert petit goût de
forêt pour passer à autre chose
mais celle très inquiet regarde
inquiétudes derrière il va avoir une
toute petite gorgée inquiétudes s'il
avait bu beaucoup les pompiers si tu
bois une fois beaucoup une petite gorgée
juste sa soif mais sa tâche est ce la
bouche l'inquiétude t'inkiet tu tapes
hussein ça va pas tous quoi tu puta
inquiet nous tu bois un petit peu non
c'est c'est terrible le quart no 6 qui
fait qu'on marche mais ouais mais alors
ces îles sont pas favoris non ils voient
les peaux savent marcher mais maintenant
c'est très très loin de maxime est guéri
qui sont quand même les deux gros favori
du tournoi après peuvent être inquiet un
dingue reach ou que tu vois qu'ils qui
sont un peu en dilettante sur les
candidats et qui repartent plus sur le
concours de marche pas ça peut être
dangereux
il faut se méfier quand même
si john wright fait la moue secours en
marchant et à bord ça s'en trouve
toujours bien et carmona qui réfléchit
il ya des jolies mocassins caruana ou
des ou des chaussures assez stylé you
lie passe de chine du doigt qui marchent
pas pour marcher mais non ils marchent
pour réfléchir
oui tu sens que dans le concours de
marchi five tu vas pas du tout menacé la
première place caruana
montre qu'à fab c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle ce c5 bien trouvé ceci ngo bien
ciblé le single sing qu ils ont bien ils
ont ils ont bien cibler la beau travail
de baky bien trouvé cette idée dans
l'ouverture ce que tu as fallait bien le
surprendre guéri et ils ont trouvé
comment c'est beau quand même alors
c'est ça que c'est pas une nouveauté un
pouvoir 150 partis plus ou moins on a
regardé mais c'est un court arrêt
évidemment là c'est pas vraiment
l'histoire de nouveautés là c'est
l'histoire de la surprise c'est une
bonne nouvelle parce qu'en fait guéri ça
se voit que du coup il se souvient pas
donc il va chercher à se remémorer mais
j'ai jamais si sûr
et ça peut faire paniquer ça arrive très
tôt dans la partie 10e coup à presse
c'est comme ça tu as deux approches en
fait soit tu cherches eu le meilleur
coup quoi qu'il arrive soit en fait
peut-être le plus malin quand tu es
vraiment en pls de truc c'est que tu
[Musique]
cherche à jouer un coup qui te sens
peut-être pas le plus ordinateur est ce
qu mais que peut-être les seconds pas
regarder pour jouer demain contre humain
quoi on attend un peu moins bien mais
solide façon laroque c'est logique mais
mais de façon tu sais que sur roc maxime
va trancher de dire et fait cavalier
hayes 6 pourquoi pas donc ils attaquent
le pion c5 un vêtement la fab mercier
france et 5
donc on s'attend à plus gros pions et je
pense qu'elle est assise c'est le coup
de se préparer il partit marché tout de
suite c'est de rattraper son retard et
des grandes enjambées l'a d'ailleurs
immédiatement taille maxi diarra lui
aussi apposé la veste pour papa trop
chauffé pour pouvoir repartir rapidement
marché médiatement de son coup je sais
très stratégique droite par les autres
quand on marche oui et non ah non en
russie n'aime pas du tout c'est vraiment
interdit par les règlements fin d'études
à bonjour c'est qu'en russie même
bonjour raymond auquel assiste peut-être
maxime autre très très fort ce qui a
valu idéalement placé évidemment avec
beaucoup mieux que le cac et b5 quoi que
très bon choix d'hier il peut être en
réponse à sharjah caruana çà çà çà
marche note quoi je ne sais pas c'est
pas de la vraie marche à ce qui se passe
à ty dillon
[Musique]
non c'est maxime qui dit c'est terrible
ce serait terrible qu'en fait il marque
arctic bas mais ça va peut être tomber
en fait non
en fait ce que je veux dire c'est que si
tu rock il va jouer tempo lui apprendre
mais si tu raques icta sont versés prend
des freins des six ce qui a aidé 8 va me
sortir quelques marques bien sûr on
décède tu peux pas donc il a priori je
sais pas enfin sega peut-être parler
d'histoire de coûts donc l'année de
checker un peu ce que ça change que ça
change rien mais je pense pas que ça
remette ça va mettre en cause grand
chose
de toute façon juste pour expliquer ce
que tu expliqué jean rapp à temps il va
revoir l' on ne sait pas quel point ben
ouais
très malin ouais en fait bon ils ont
pris ce prix zfu quelque part foot est
roi et la ja paca et d'essai puisqu'elle
comprend des six la dame ne le
protègerait plus d'eau qui seraient
obligés de sortie fin qui sera obligé
pas s'ils veulent sortir séparation et
donc ça c'est une vision qu'on pourrait
avoir dans la partie avec le cake a
relancé cette ou en b 4 ou 11 et 5 que
je ne sais pas d'où ça transposerait pas
avoir la même position via cavalia si ce
qui a été joué dans la partie puis on
prend fou prend fou d'être à rock
après bon faut être honnête feu 2 7 août
et 3 peut être un autre coup mais en
gros à ça revient donc
donc oui je pense a pas changé apa m
maxime or préparation juste un ordre de
coups différents donc tu dois regarder
cette subtilité irakien sirote pas si
vite peut-être ce qui peut pas utiliser
ce tempo à faire autre chose ou je sais
pas je n'ai pas la préparer
qui va laisser peut-être juste de ce
problème de se rappeler dans le bon
ordre
quand tu vois j'ai envie de te dire mais
qui a eu lieu à 6 soit c'est un coup
encaissé pas mal raison bien
sérieusement rocks en normal mais qui
assistent pourquoi pas
puis on prend des essais soit bon ça
c'est attendu chanson avoir guéri voler
vers le photographe le fou qu'on y vive
prend dès 6h30 directement sa peau qui
ne pourra pas te lever et j'ai interdit
et il repart au board eric olhats oui
mais oui il refaire un petit pas de plus
basse et c'est très bien vu là et a
perdu un minimum de temps là passage au
stand rapide vraiment les techniciens
très bon pour changer en s'asseyant et
je le prends d'ici les cris et les
scolaires en glissant sur la chaise à
ces techniques là ce qui vient de faire
à nice non non c'est à vue il a laissé
sa chaise un petit peu ouverte pour se
ré à ce récit détaillé le haut niveau et
tu vois il est reparti chance comme le
favori du concours de marche aguerris je
parie que celui qui se lève vraiment le
plus et qui marche le vide non on n'a
pas vous prendre et c'est ce qu'ils
peuvent jouer debout
je pense simplement pas très bien vu sa
demande à un niveau de déficit très
élevés quoi bon on s'attend au 2e point
de foot deux manches ans avoue ça la
question je sais pas ces quatre mois je
verrai plus que detroit en fait parce
que detroit sont une gêne la défense
deux des cinq de prendre des cadets f54
perdre du temps ya trop de choses qui
ont voté que ce fonds détroit du coup
ses quatrains peut-être dans la fosse et
4 pourquoi ces quatre ne faut pas trop
d'autres coups par d'autres
je pense que c'est logique en fait y'a
pas d'autres coûts qui est prandelli si
je pense pas non c'était le temps de
faire plus tard basso s'il faut s'en va
mais bon donc c'est soit l'un soit
l'autre bafoue détroit quand même ça
reste dans le orange dès qu'on le
signale m haies dames à 81 kg ensemble
qui fait peur aux irakiens damas 4w quoi
qu'elle ne pouvait pas prendre il peut
toujours prendre le cas ici qu'il
prendra me prend pas
que chez hyperassur après le c5 tempo et
irréfléchie la maxime qui se met à
réfléchir
est ce que c'est encore prépa ou pas bon
au pire
c'est sympa c'est une partie d'échecs et
nouvelle sympa
après je pense que vraiment s'il
réfléchit c'est plus par par pas faire
de conneries dans les ordres de coûts je
serais étonné
d'autres choses ce qu'il peut y avoir
beaucoup de finesse dans les ordres de
coûts dans quoi on s'attend à quoi vous
ces quatre petirin qu'un petit rock et
maintenant décider s'ils vont ces 7 ce
qui va lancer cette je touche prises des
6 tu provoques un homme prend et c'est
cette position évaluer d'autres à 4 pour
pas se prendre des cinq sapeurs de fou
la paire de fouta pions des cinq pas au
top avec des baies 3 x 3 finalement
j'aime bien les blancs après même des
tours à 3 en fait c'est les plans
peuvent pas être moins bien je pense ici
mais bon bon en fait ok si l'option des
cinq un jour vendée si ce sera peut-être
très grave un point noir donc là ce qui
advient ce qu'on a mis la dame en
bloqueurs
c'est la pièce la pire alors que le
cavalier dessus serait pas mal il y
arrivera jamais non être voilées en huit
ans devrait bouger la dame de fer cahier
des six est très lent et les blancs
grand temps de faire des choses pour
l'instant donc ce genre de position ça
peut arriver mais ça paraît cohérent
après la 4g au final de 6,84 foudroie
aussi il faut 3 vous demandez est ce que
laissait b5 ce cas c'est une option
ces quatre crocs après qui sait cette
semble logique mais ce que on peut pas
faire f 5 va faire des coups à voir
maxime qui arrive plein de grains de
poussière tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui le joueur de poker je sais
pas
bon je trouve qu'il est un peu c'est le
room service ou fall émis une idée me
jouer jouer les candidats jennifer le
room service que je pars en fait il faut
le petit plus molle c'est la nouvelle
wii jeu cricket et commander si je crois
aux échecs mais si je fais le ménage
dans les shebab ont fait mais bon il
souffle quoi il va jouer l'échiquier
manar bien propre c4 ok donc
bon je me droguais est peut-être que
kessé cette dame or c'est quelque chose
où il a pu se relever ah oui un se
venger il est vraiment très inquiet
petites gorgées inquiétudes
lui habite côté néerlandais
c'est déplacé meilleure tactique pour
pas voir ça sent trop longtemps beaucoup
du joueur français
ah ben on en dire tout de suite quoi
merga a fait un truc qu'on ai dit que
c'était qu'il n'était pas autorisé tout
à l'heure je sais pas dans quel point
mais il s'est hissé à 6 il sert est
assis sur le temps de maxime et il s'est
relevé notamment
non mais c'était des concentrations camp
fait suite été levée et ultra nord
solvay en fait tu as en fait attendre
que l'adversaire d'ailleurs ne demande
rien passerait après si vraiment tu fais
exprès de t'asseoir comme un agro avachi
à faire du bruit at on relevé a soufflé
la t'éclater chiant quoi mais tu peux
t'asseoir trafic de minutes bon mais je
veux toujours pas tu te relèves
j'ai déjà vu mille fois dans les
tournois et même si quelqu'un me le fais
ça me dérange pas aller l'a clairement
fait alors il est repassé à six mois
après la blessure s'il fait assis debout
toutes les dix secondes tu choisis tu
vas faire ton marathon on va te faire
autre chose mais bon sa recherche toute
irrégularité côté néerlandais ici un ca
sont allées on a les vidéos je trie ge
servette ses récits lorsqu'il est
concentrée guiry et même très concentré
mais on n'arrive pas à savoir si koné ou
s'y connaît pas en fait ça c'est
vraiment dur de juger fait ce qu'il a
réussi à se remémorer puisque ce qui
l'est déjà vu c'est sur ce qu'il a
réussi à se remémorer de sa prépa de son
fichier sans il a three intense
transparaître un rush la toux ceux qui
connaissent pas ben moi aussi mais on
d'accord que dix ans il ya deux choses
qui font dire ça sans fin outre sa
réputation bien sûr c'est oui sa
réputation est la deuxième chose c'est
que son second dans la sueur le tournoi
va d'arman qui avait fait la prépa de
ouf pour oran de forest lawn à un monde
comprend des lieux ont en effet la vidéo
sur le chêne
les déjà joué donc en gros tu as
quelqu'un ton entourage qui est un
spécialiste en fin ou pas mais qui a
déjà je la variante normalement étant
éteinte
il tendit de troisvaux dessus quoi ah au
fait j'ai déjà joué ça t'as vu ce qu'est
ce tu as préparé dessus c'est dangereux
c'est si c'est la reine donc bon sens ce
serait hyper étonnant quoi mais d'un
autre côté sur pareil si t'as pas
regarder le truc depuis deux trois
quatre semaines serait étonnant quand
même parce qu'il joue je fais chenilles
comme il ya du tout révisé au revoir et
ce qui peut avoir des trous de mémoire à
cause de la pression
est ce que la pression influe sur la
mémoire c'est bah en fait des fois avant
un examen ou quoi ou non une offre
complète du coup tu peux avoir le
syndrome du trou de mémoire car on ne
sait plus rien mais normalement quand tu
fais ça revient juste ça revient à
mécaniquement donc mais juste avant tu
meurs mais je sais plus les gens qui
disent ça arrive
le manque de mémoire par pression va
peut-être il se met la pression il a
gagné hier il redevient
j'ai en course pour gagner les candidats
et peut-être qui sut et cl femmes au zoo
le trou de mémoire
et comme dirait le grand philosophe la
tcat chef tu vois un trou qui
entretiennent entre elles
peut-être qu'il est rentré dans la
maxime le syndrome de la page blanche
fait le son de la page blanche sait pas
plus que tu apprennes à écrire c'est pas
mon âme à ses jantes et écrivain et t'as
rien à raconter en fait je pose la
question ça peut être une page blanche
que tu te fais moi aussi j'ai toujours
entendu dans ce sens en fait le syndrome
de la page blanche
peu importe je pense que c'est le
syndrome de di tweet le verbal en sueur
chat est d'accord avec moi c'est une
bonne chose
c'est quoi le si mal en tout cas ce
persiste kaspersky c'est les antivirus
les autres simone vahland le pli de
simone quoi ouais ce que j'aimerais
cimade crois en fait je peux regarder si
mal andré logo si mal en un peu de
partout c'est goûter d'autres non mais
sinon j'ai franchement je pense que si
mme allende ayant dauphin si mal en
point route entre kyriat du dauphin
highway s'immolant de dauphin mais
hamsik russe marya jolie si mal n à g
les catalogues boulet à 10 millions de
tavares d'astaffort mosquée terrain
bourg saint pétersbourg par russia c'est
année c'est vraiment dauphin leur logo
et il sait de la vente en ligne en
russie donc c'est un genre d'amazon
russe optimal hand avec un logo de
dauphin c'est terrible ils ont un état
grave et ou céder notre élan point minsk
minsk c'est devant des trucs devrait
jouer à la con ils sont très très
choquant le sponsor des dauphins et
que je les vois depuis l'autre jour on a
jamais vu ce que c'était ce si mal on va
ses deux dauphins quoi ça va attendre
jusqu'au quai je connais pas j'ai jamais
vu mais bon du coup ils font livraison
hamouda s'est assis sur la friche
également d'urgence ça triche beaucoup
lacan cependant à fabien il a vu le
dauphin il était dégoûté il est reparti
quoi il est partout le dauphin il faut
revoir ce qui suppose d'un combat entre
le dauphin est le cheval de la fidh ils
sont d'autres dos-à-dos d'air assez dur
à dire qu'on doit d'offrir des bâches
valton fera pas un tigre non mais d'ado
foudroie par ellis qu'il ya un dauphin
sur leurs bouteilles également observé
dur aussi pour maxime passé j'assume et
des dauphins partout un parti pour
lequel côté bras nulle part mais
peut-être un peu plus agréable pour
maxime quoi qu'on puisse en acquérir
pour battre un cheval puissant mais au
fait quoi oui ce tube fait un petit tour
des stades pendant qu'il a fléchi et qui
sucre alors népoui la page ou 4g va
jouer une sorte de réty anglaise
c'est cette gamme kia un problème a
partout j'ai mal dimensionné
deux parties sont toutes plutôt
intéressante bon sur le papier ou en
goguette shoote pas trop parce que parce
que ça va pas jouer pour le titre mais
les autres c'est intéressant teint
caruana adding ses partisans d'une
espagnole c'est le début sentir la
texture mais juste voir ce qu'il avance
rapide cinq cavaliers 3 qui mange mange
et très haut noir on verra bien caruana
qui aura narines vans adding 34 les deux
quoi ça à peu près c'est pas il n'y a
pas un fossé 4 de fou dans cette partie
en tout cas ok ça joue et l'autre
l'autre séné peau avec 5 go way donc
c'est ça c'est un récit anglaise
pourquoi pas qui arrive trois il prend
confiance et 4 il va récupérer que damas
quatre qui décèdent pas mal il a fouillé
à fouler cette c6 aussi des coûts rock
ses cinq essais 3 en fait pour résumer
en deux mots mais nord ça pas mal mais
c'est toujours compliqué de développer
le faisait vite et les blancs
généralement ils vont ok je pense assez
vite et soit tu prépares un tour d un
des quatre pour ouvrir la position à ton
avantage soit tu essayes juste aussi
d'éviter b5
tu peux faire des a4 des choses comme ça
et puis je vais peut-être poussé au
centre avec le cas donc t'as pas mal de
plans possibles mais je pense que wayne
rock des quatre c'est peut-être le plus
logique surtout quand fawcett était joué
parce que quand tu fais des princes et
saint caprais tu fait perdre un temps à
reprendre certains petits détails qui
ce qui fait que ça peut être intéressant
mais on verra ça va être une partie un
peu plus positionnelle après ça peut
vite tourner à bien sûr mais mais qu'il
cherche pas le ce match est une prépa ou
quoi mais pour une partie là c'est
typique ce dont parlait nostra de l'anus
là encore dans le pré candidats à l'epo
il aime bien sa position stratégique oui
mais la pression petit avantage un + 0
c'est un peu ça spécial ouais on me
reverra correction qui va très bien joué
en avinés pour danger pour alex et une
quoi surtout qu'en plus tu vois ça
ressemble à une grünfeld inversée
quelque part failli oui bien sûr il est
un peu dans ses schémas quelque part
c'est une couille l'habitude de jouer
les slaves et ça peut ressembler à des
slaves aussi bon qu'on le sorte quand tu
as les pions des essais qui sait qui tu
sais la même structure ils sont sous les
eaux dans leur structure mais j'ai peur
pour alex enhco parce que si tu te
prends mais un truc comme ça
en fait tu t'en fous ils peuvent
vraiment rester à 100 points c'est vrai
que les blancs une fois un tour des
infos f4 ou g5 l'autre tours en c1 ça
c'est gros avantage non humaines puis
puis c'est chiant ouais moi j'aime bien
jouer c'est truqué que les blancs en
fait mais c'est souvent du rabbin en
fait le truc sur damas quatre échecs
je sais pas à payer une variante qui est
plutôt jouer maintenant s'il faut 17 en
fait je sais pas tu as changé d'âme
français 4 c 5 k -o 5
ça pourrait te prendre ces 6 mai de fond
dames c'est 800 foot et ont quand même
de faire pousser 6 est pas une partie de
kericho qu'avec les noirs le film est en
fait en gros tu peux tu peux rockets ou
quoi peu importe ils vont de fer qui
haïssez 6 / rock
il sait si ce bon je viens tu prends la
perte fouda me prend en fait ça c'est
sous une toile à nous faire fausse être
autour des huit pages suivantes
le touquet en décalé noir blanc beiges
avait un peu analysé avec toi mais en
fait je me demande comme ça en fait ce
truc de fou fait d'amal 417 c'était
juste conservé comme pas bon enfin pas
terrible à cause au casting pour la
perte oui je me rappelle je savais après
ses grilles dieu qui a joué ça et en
fait ça va quoi
du coup je me pose la question si moi
j'ai joué pas mal de parties avec les
blancs sur cette vente et j'adorais a
convoqué 17 ou c6 je connaissais fin je
veux pas dire soit génial pour les
blancs mais ce bon sens mais à quoi tu
joues ton truc tu n'as pas de risque 17
bon j'ai pas de grande idée de comment
prendre l'aventage quoi on retournera
maximo finnois bien sûr c'est notre
maison et objet tout juste une française
mme façon ils ont tous les deux à -11 1
et n'ont plus aucune chance de gagner
pas de chance mais ça va pas leur action
grignan réflexion mail et yahoo pour
gagner alors pas du tout un super rambo
hilali dans la course mais il n'est pas
leader mais y ait dans la course il ya
un demi point du leader donc c'est rien
si aujourd'hui maxime gagné koné peau
fait nul par exemple mais revient
ex-aequo au classement classement donc
qu'on voyait dépôt donc joueurs russes
dont on arriverait partie juste avant
qu'ils en tête avec 5 ennemis lui a
vraiment essayé de gagner
ils jouent contre alex un coq et le
joueur sur le papier le plus faible du
tournoi et et à côté il ya voilà il ya
maxime vous vivez dans le groupe des
poursuivants avec guiry son adversaire
du jour donc partie contre un concurrent
direct évidemment très intéressante et
il ya caruana qui jouent contre le
dernier du temps à dingli rennes mais
qui normalement sur le papier pas
pas le plus femme coincée entre mondiale
dont claudine guyane en fait il paye son
tournoi à l'est était jeu il ya un an en
fait il était plutôt en forme bien sûr
on se souvient c'était le début du colis
non plus mais en chine avait dû subir
des quarantaines n'étais pas dans mon
état de forme optimal et a trop bien
joué qu'on peut le dire
et donc ils se retrouvent hors course
mais bon bah là maintenant depuis un an
a passé et il revient bossard fait
peut-être un peu la cerise
alors je sais pas évidemment le manque
de pratique ça aide pas jouer ses
meilleurs échec mais c'est pas un gars
facile à battre
enfin avant de le faire je préfère
prévenir on m'a dit hier que je mettais
pas assez de pub donc là tu as de la
chance qu'on va station doit mettre six
minutes de plus par heure donc j'ai
envoyé trois minutes la wii ne fait pas
le choix
enfin c'est juste pour dire désolé les
gars par avance on envoie trois minutes
de pub alors savoir pourquoi ils ont vu
qu'il ya beaucoup trop de gens qui
regardent est fini on va se faire
baisser l'audience m'étais bien vingt
minutes de pub d'affilée alors juste
pour dire un truc pour pas que vous
soyez frustré sur les os rim ils ont
pour consigne de faire entre cinq et
quinze minutes de pause toutes les
heures on est les salles a pas faire de
pause
donc du coup bien prenez ça comme une
pause désolé les gars nous on aime bien
faire du non-stop et enfin moi sur ma
chaîne perso j'en ai eu une itt depuis
toutes les 2h ou 3h enfin quand j'y
pense je pense l escrime de 10 heures
sans pub mais la voilà c'est un petit
peu obligé donc je mets les 3 min
maintenant à ceux qui n'ont pas la pub
parce que tant mieux pour envoie pas la
pub à tout le monde donc ça qu'ils n'ont
pas à tant mieux pour vous mais ceux qui
sont abonnés n'ont pas de puberg ceux
qui sont enfin face à bague aussi bon
pour ceux qu'on voit la plume en d'être
journal préféré prévenir avant de mettre
une pub longue
du coup
ces quelques couleurs l'échiquier te
demande de faire avec le blême et 6 kg
et zapper même chose mais c'est par
vagues à travers ses filles mais il ya
des petites nuances de quelque chose est
vraie dans différents ces chantiers
marbre marbre s'insurge m l'hôtel chic
et ont même pas forcément on voit très
bien sur moi je préfère le bleu en fait
j'aime bien les cercles et marne
il est un peu comme les couleurs du
contour là c'est ça un peu doré sablé
[Musique]
tube de 15 secondes tu peux avoir de la
chance qui est pas assez de pub et qui
publie pas y en a pour tout le monde
je ferai prévenir pour les gens qui vont
se prendre trois minutes tu vois pas ce
que c'est un peu frustrant
weston bon ça va vous serez un gros
tacle clé partie pédagogique de mazo
pendant la nuit blanche c'est donc il
cavalli ses sept finales rock rock la
ssn annoncé sa position qu'on avait et
donc on pense à qui il prend des six
pour faire venir ben déjà tu prends la
perte de fous tu fais venir la dame sur
la case bloqueurs et alors qu'on sait
pas fou 3 à 4 et bientôt à 4 4 c'est
utile ça gagne la casse v5 sa vraie part
du a5 et tu veux payer trois fois 3 au 6
mai ce qui peut voir venir avec son
camion à 6 allant peut-être maintenant
la direccte je voulais prendre le ton et
toi tu fais à 5
ok on va tu me connais quoi moi je suis
très direct alors leur disent qu'ils se
sentent peut-être ordi baisse de 5 mais
ces sujets avec la même idée prescrit
sous trois mois
bien ça pour les blancs pâturages du job
en plus c'est dans le style de maxime ça
peut faire peur un pion donne active
ouais le kg de lait n'est pas fait alors
c'est pas un isolat ni c'est un pion
passe assez isolée ça change tout un
plus si dans des 5es pas en d4
après avoir vu le vidéo sur le point
isolé de vlad enfin là c'est très très
grave
faites ce serait grave si le feu était
enfin grave c'est très différent s'il
soutient et en d4 et l'autre en
réussissent mais là le pion blanc a
dépassé le pion aux 5
donc il est passé parce qu'il n'a plus
de il ya plus de pions sur les colonnes
adjacentes pour l'arrêter et c'est
complètement différent un pion isolé
d'un pion passé isolé un dessin qu'il
est complètement différent assez peu
avancé il peut aller très loin
jusqu'au bout je suis pas dans le carré
voilà pour le coulis et même nom et
j'aimais bien notre truc en fait je suis
très heureux de jouer à 4 en mai alors
nouvelle tentative à 5 des noirs beau
cadeau et maintenant ça change tout et
fait ça allait se change son nom aurait
pu garder f4 qui partait tout ce que
j'ai ressenti à 5 à 4 temps quand ils
s'approchent pas c'est complètement ma
faveur de noms je vois je sais des
couples non moi je ne me sens pas mes
galettes sur le bois des petites gorgées
d'eau avec les mardis fait b 3 way
cheval est à lire ici
4-4 mais si je sais pas ça se sent bien
droite ça vient et gauche maxime qui
relie les coûts sur la question et je
veux l'être au fameux petit en quoi il a
mille riscle il a mal notés quoi c'est
pas poli si tout reprendre à zéro les
lacets la notation qu'est ce qu'ils font
petit fait des petits smiley quoi il met
des gros points d'interrogation sur les
coûts de grille
qu'est ce qui chez un truc qui sent que
maxime est pas fondée par rentrer dans
son tour a complètement encore non c'est
pas une autre là je sais pas ce qui
m'attend pour le coup si notebook ou
quoi c'est le death note élimination
l'élimination
tu as aimé qu'ils vont tomber les uns
après les autres tours c'est marrant bon
après que
on est six à quatre c'est quand même la
logique hein j'aime bien mais il a pas
l'air non il n'y a que moi qui ai cette
impression je sais pas y a pas l'air
bien
qu'est-ce que mazola fait manger après
ça veut pas forcément dire grand chose
mais c'est pas je le sens un peu après
il a beaucoup joué hier avant-hier il
peut être un peu fatigué par par les
princes partie précédente mais je le
sens pas fringants comme il peut l'être
parfois ça donne pas cette impression
femmes n'ont pas le truc en fait je
regarde jamais trop le comportement des
jarres de l'échiquier quoi je le regarde
je me dis tu vires tracasser je vais
avoir coiffé par sa fille de party je
crois peut-être s'y essaye de se
rappeler on sera prêt pas ils se
rattachent pas aux 14e kouyias à
couffoulens arrière mois les sushis ont
eu raison des joueurs français et à
l'air agacé
non mais ça sera très bien enfin j'ai
pas trop quoi dire
mais ouais mais j'imagine il prend le
fou il fait à quatre c'est pas mal quoi
il peut faire du blé 3 x 3 peut être la
tour et peut faire un f4 t'as plein de
petits plants avec les noirs bas après
ça sent aujourd'hui il sera pas en
danger en france par une position les
plans puissent se retrouver mal non mais
bon il faut qu'on regarde un peu plus et
prend des systèmes prend des six à
quatre tours d'éviter que des infos 6,6
way
est ce qu'on peut faire autre chose que
de mettre en bras 3 way qui prend des
cinq tours des trois faux 6 détroit
l'implémentation mais là c'est pas
simple
alors ça c'est là c'est pas ça qu'est ce
qui fait encore sur sa feuille quoi
c'est vraiment bizarre du oui je sais
pas mais
je sais parfaitement s'en fout là fait
deux parties c'est juste un truc qu'on
est obligé de noter des trucs dessus
mais en soit on s'en fiche mais il faut
savoir le numéro du coup en allant voir
sûrement sur les écrans doit être écrit
au niveau du cou de poissons blancs et
enfin pierre prennent feuille blanche
sur notre lait coule les skis sont être
même donc du coup qui a quatre tombes
tour des huit ce que c'est un mod
defense option un cadre du coup on peut
les lumières mais c'est dommage on
aimait bien le plan mais en dépit de
cette option l'anticipaient peut-être
prendre prendre d'hommes pour préparer
tournaire mais bon du coup le vent de
sud est 5 c'est pas possible
bessin et qui défoule bus a de quoi bien
s'inquiète houssin c'est hyper compliqué
tu peux
six ados et mais bon comme ça ça joue
mais je veux dire les noirs c'est pas
quand on a besoin et b34 machin gibbons
balle fois avant à trois et efficace
tu prend l'eau de partout là tout d'un
coup ça joue mais alors oui si tu peux
pas vraiment jouer davantage là dessus
et bouffe ou trop attendait 8 j'ai une
idée oui si on parle plus on renforce un
peu j'imagine qu'on peut le perdre ou de
courtes pauses et faire nul mais quant à
lui de la partie
5nous jolies fringues pour ça peut très
bien être assainie l'entente ouais bon
et du coup si on prend pour des six ça
paraissait tellement logique de prendre
des six mais en fait vous
je vous paye a pas d'autres couquet
france et z c'est quand même trop
bizarre tu vas te faire dame prend et
f54 est fou g5 intermédiaires je vois
pas à quoi ça peut servir aux firmes m
dames prendront de 9,6 soit ça peut être
ça peut-être
il faut distinguer six juste envie que
ça change de trois trucs
[Musique]
est un peu clown partout après ce que ça
change vraiment quelque chose je sais
pas mais ok peut-être peut-être pas mais
ok peut-être fou g5 la mairie qui
prenait 6 il semble évident évident pas
tout simple tout cas langage de maxime
suis d'accord avec le chat qui n'est pas
encourageant
tu as l'impression qu'ils aient pas les
incas max quelles sont les conditions
pour la nulle bas les gens puissent
proposer une tu veux faire nul parce que
trop fort et ma position je suis amer
parce que 50 coups sans coup de pouce
emprise plein de pression de propos
sibilité nul après la prison un nombre
minimum pour faire nul taux de 40 coups
40 coup je crois qu'il pensait des fois
il joue jusqu'au 40e coup il a pas l'air
il a pas l'air dans son assiette un nom
mais bon il peut jouer la ligne 2 nuls
ce qu'elle est facile oui et on en parle
plus on en parle plus on se repose en
repart d'attac après quoi après ses
déceptions peut-être parce qu'on était
chaud après ses cinq ont regarni suez
mais bon je sais pas quel point issue il
ya un tissu adipeux est sûr de se
souvenir de ce qu'il le set up il vient
de mettre en place s'appelle rio il se
dirige vers l'option des 5 ne fait pas
ça qui la tête mal au ventre avec les
gens il se tient peu vaseux
j'ai des maux d'estomac parfois ça a
l'impression qu'un des maux d'estomac
parce que moi aussi j'ai c'est qu'on
généralise tomates je sais pas le
ballonnet quoi bah ça me brûle un ennemi
quoi ouais c'est chiant pour toucher les
bobards d'estomac c'est chiant home est
bon pour le coup moi juge usep ce matin
au téléphone m'ont parlé d'eux des stars
de stage et kouamé il m'a pas dit m ça
va pas ou quoi donc ses patins salaire
maximum de trois ans
donc ça va mais bon c'est sûr que la
posture qu'on voit là c'est pas une
compostière conquérante mais je n'aime
pas le majorat erwin comme ça son cheval
quoi oui hélas il donne son coeur il dit
va quoi même avec un seul bras mais s'en
fout on s'en fout complètement c'est à
l'intéressement en fait les aura on les
mettrait du temps à armin non oui je ne
sais pas si je peux me transporte anti
temps je n'y arrive pas à moi de vendre
qui me retour mais beaucoup trop dur
terrible notre côté qui rit on n'imagine
pas ce transformant titan non plus c'est
pas trop mais pau il fait un petit temps
ouais c'est inquiétant je sais pas
fendant même temps voilà
fondamentalement changé dans les
couloirs gris on va te dire tu fais ces
cinq-là remonte à regarder tout ça alors
je sais pas si c'est que c'est de
regarder sa fin et regarde c'est bizarre
en fait il ya quelque chose qui va pas
sa part fait peut-être que dans sa
mémoire il sait qu'au numéro 15 fou 3
pas je dis un truc comme ça tu as ouais
il comprend pas mais comment je présage
de ce coût aux 15e et qu'ils soient bien
f1 j'ai pas [ __ ] occasion sa prépa je
sais pas qui c'est qui a un coût
important et qui se dit mais merde mais
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi là
c'est n'importe quoi si jusqu'au 15e ce
que des fois j'ai ça moi aussi je sais
pas pourquoi tu as comme ça béchir est
basée la notation à côté je sais pas tu
vois 12 machin tu n'as pas déclamation
thieffry retiennent 12e coup ça me fait
un point de repère quoi tu es là puis ma
douzième coup je sais plus quoi tu bois
tu sais plus et maxime durand du coup
c'était le 13 et que t'es con enfin je
sais pas en fait c'est vrai qu'ils
regardent beaucoup trop la feuille pour
que pour soi naudin et puis même
continué sa position un peu avachi ce
n'est pas une position il réfléchissait
sur la partie c'est vraiment une
position où tu pensif pensif ouais mais
pas pensif de l'échiquier qui revient il
regarde sa feuille machin il sera fier
puis re buy bon après faut dire que ce
matin après pas là pas dû être facile
quoi non surtout regarder oui tu sais
pas si elle est répétée là j'ai bien
joué à 16 heures en deux jours j'ai peur
il a été les prépas a vanté crevé mais
clairement non ça c'est sûr mais je sais
pas à se mettre des suppositions j'ai
aucune idée de quel problème ou si a pas
de problème mais en tout cas ça sent la
fatigue est musulman et un truc ce que
genre de sortir fumer mais je pense que
oui mais je pense que
je fume sur l'angle est choqué c'est ou
non trop qui est un petit train qui
arriveront juste qui arrive parfois
combien de geri contrite en titrant
colossal face à lui mais mal quoi
peut-être même pas de nom de guiry
suffisant quoi ce genre impossible tu
tant que le sol trop fort possible à 22
millions nous dit un million de dire non
c'est pas vrai il faut treize mur maria
et 5 millions de grilles à leur défense
autour des chevaux partout donc maxime
qui est pas bien et après comme on l'a
dit en préambule un là nul aujourd'hui
c'est pas un mauvais résultat
non vous voudra une bonne partie pour
bien lancer tous à mettre le cerveau à
l'endroit que les couches soit fluide
avoir une bonne position
mettre un peu de pression qui sait à
gagner une partie ça fait très plaisir
mais en soit nul ça va pire c'est même
attendu on va dire qu'on résultats de
base
non ce qui est un petit peu ça je suis
un petit peu dommage c'est que maxime
fait deux fois qu'il fait une fois et
demie qui subit quand même des prépas et
réussit pas en faire subir une à son
adversaire après ces jours le mieux
préparé c'est pas non plus il a fait
subir un truc mais
je vois pas pourquoi pas de suite parce
que c'est pour ça il apparaît vraiment
fait subir enfin il ya un truc mais pas
jusqu'au bout quoi tentative est ce qui
pourrait bluffé nan là il bluffe pas non
ça aurait pu être du bluff s'il avait
réfléchi un peu moins longtemps mais là
ça devient trop long comme cwf ces
boeufs bluff corporelle kasparov était
capable de les faire ses bluffs la wii
espoir infime il pouvait à simuler
l'énervement secouer la tête faire
n'importe quoi dire que maxime soit
connu pour ça non plus ce qui est très
marrant avec espoir si on pouvait faire
des bluffs mais en milieu de partie
alors qu'en fait je fais dans
l'ouverture du film et qui connaît pas
tous savons c'est connu il fait déjà
relevé équipe a bien eu une complication
et puis l'autre en dedans à la bami de
sortie du coup tempo très heureux classe
il te claquent les pièces et mais voilà
comme les arbitres en arbitres masqué
ouais c'est vrai personne massif
d'armements et rabbit masqué surgit quoi
bon faire raser mais depuis le début bon
si tu veux on peut faire un peu beaucoup
de coups
on attend peut-être la fin de la pub ok
après la pub
après la pub du coup tout le monde est
là le petit résumé de cette partie je
n'ai pas grand chose à dire non et pas
grand chose y'a pas grand chose c'est
qu'on peut se poser la question à qui il
prend dé 6,2 me prendrait six mère du
fai retour des huitièmes auprès des 5
après l'autre la petite claque on a
trouvé qu'il faut trois matches à bah
oui c'est quand même il direct et en
plus j'ai pas regardé mardi quand je
proposais les coûts c'est juste logique
en fait de farine comme ça nathan s
l'autre tournant d'un
doit chercher un gain
c'est pas tant que cherche un gain si
tôt il cherche un truc qui joue avec une
certaine pression ce que tu vas gagner
en dix coups alors que toulouse et que
des coups normaux souvent mais est-ce
que la pub est terminée n'ont toujours
pas forcément ça dépend pour qui
on ne sait pas c'est pas une partie
passionnante un prolongement femmes on
est à une heure de jeu passe pas grand
chose finalement
ouais c'est pas le rythme habituel
d'habitude en fait il ya la pause mais
plus tard voilà ça fait transport une
pause c'est bien ça a posé direct c'est
pas une position finalement on ait
l'impression qu'il est blanc puisse
vraiment mettre la pression ares que il
s'est trompé avant après on y croyait
mais à ce qu'elles pouvaient genre ne
par ok et faire un 4 shifter progresse
notamment l'écouté ou peut-être juste c5
c'est peu joué parce que ça vanne rien
on devrait quand même se dit posible été
bien surpris tu sais tu
non mais est-ce que c'est pas pareil tu
sais comme c'est un petit coup c'est
peut-être un petit coup en fait il rien
peut-être une idée quand même nom mais
peut-être qu'à une idée si l'autre se
tromper peut-être que ça c'est le set up
avec les noirs on t'a jamais d'idée la
souhaite le temps dont tu peux alors le
résumé des amis maxime blanc qui a joué
4 sans surprise est guéri on peut
s'attendre à plein de choses mais pas
tellement surprenant il a répété ce
qu'il est je comprenais pas ou alors on
a un c'est à dire la défense chez smic
of de la sicilienne
donc c'est l'ouverture qu'il a préparé
pour ces candidats normalement il en
dérangera pas voilà encore que ouais bon
maintenant c'est de là deux fois donc
c'est ce coup cinq là alors quoi dire
tout ce coup c'est un coût qui attaquent
le cavalier donc sa force les bleus à
bouger encore ça gagne de l'espace peut
parfois pour mettre au foot sortir assez
loin mais tu as deux problème c'est que
tu te fais un pion arriérés et ça libère
cette liasse que de sympa pour les
blancs utiliser au maximum de kébé 5
c'est toujours comme ça qu'on cherche à
poser des problèmes avec les blancs
noirs parce que si tu cavaillon le recul
le truc très simple à savoir ses canards
peuvent se développer en clouant le
cavalier du coup l'option est attaqué et
quand on le défend les normes un conte
un goût thématiques qu'ils adorent jouer
dans ce cas dans cette ouverture là et
qui leur donne même l'avantagé très vite
cette sphère des cinq ce qu'on avait dit
que le problème des normes telles puis
en arriérés et la case forte pour les
blancs blaya ni l'un ni l'autre
les noirs du goût story capture centrale
pas les blancs on est de doubler les
pions femmes de gagner un pion on va
carrément doubler les pions très
facilement le fou peut rentrer les
normands hockey où la vie est belle
comme un pion central compte zéro donc
roja consorts le fou on peut faire du f
5 très facile à jouer très bien pour les
noir et en fait on comprend très bien
que bah du coup les blancs face kébé 5
parce que les états et là bas aura un
autre coup qui pourrait sembler logiques
parfois se fait recaler f5 et on se dit
je veux venir là si je me fais chasse et
j'aimerais que trois jeux contrôler la
case stratégiquement très bien pensé
mais concrètement il ya ce coup un peu
chiant c'est le couple et noir veut le
faire surcharge du pion si on prend les
noirs se venge alors ses pairs pas de
pièce parce qu'on songe là dessus mais
on voit bien qu'il ya pas de souci et
pour pour toutes ces raisons là il faut
faire qui est bilingue
donc on menace de rentrée donc on laisse
pas le temps aux noirs de faire leur
petit truc et fauve et 4 ou quoi puisque
le quai vallet bien faire échec
bah ils empêchent et pendant de
nombreuses décennies le coup joué
quasiment toujours au niveau ça a été
fou g5
ça fait une pierre deux coups ça
développe un fou ça tous les cavaliers
et donc ça joue pour le contrôle de
cette case ça je vous montre le cette
case parce que lecavalier pourrait venir
est fou princesse on voit qu'il a joué
il ya des changements des six résumé il
a fait qu'aider 5 dans cette cour
initiés enfin qu'il existe aussi
durement mais par caruana contre 47 au
match dernière fois et là ils ont joué
saleucami attaqué il ya deux cases
possible il a choisi d'entrer à la
maison c'est possible enfin c'est pas
plus mal
maxime a joué ses 4o qui est logique
fawcett est là la surprise est venue
avec secousses et 5 très rare l'idée
c'est que prise n'est pas possible parce
qu'il ya des six attaques le fou aussi
bouge fourchette la partie sur le champ
geary semblait suez i
il réfléchit il a joué le coup qui a
valu à 6 après une longue réflexion
bon ça naze juste de reprendre le pion à
maxime a donc pris feu prend il s'est
développé rock rock il y revient à
propose les changes et on en était là et
puis ça y est ça a joué du coup il ya eu
qu'à y prend des six passionnés de la
position de 36 et dames f3 attaque donc
le fou on pense qu'il va rester la
défense du pion et on sait pas s'il faut
b 7 6 et 5 6 à 5
moi j'avais parlé de trouver cette un
coup parmi tant d'autres
autour des 8 ouais non mais toi moi ça
joue et c'est maxime brand pasdarans de
foot recours poser ou quoi ok bon des
mecs trop intéressante
et voilà donc pour le petit résumé
rapide qui montre on en a qu'on écoute
réparer mon premier basse après par tour
des mains pour défendre des cinq et on
se laisse pas bouffer le bien autour des
aussi à noter que peut-être un jour si
la dame des six part il y aura un petit
des six qui pourra partir parce que on
va viser la diva le retour à vide ont
visé vii xi l'autre côté voilà il ya eu
mais bombay cinq mois ça me semble hyper
hyper hyper logique c'est pour ça que je
voulais faire à 4 200 fait pour pas les
cb 500 messages en parlant des 3 ok mais
faut baisser le wef 5h pas bon si je
fais phobie 7 ckoi déjà c'est pas un
truc très logique de base
moi j'ai six puisque dame mais peut-être
on peut donner qualité sahara hyper
dangereux pour les plantes ça moi je
crois qu'il valait 1 b arrive patron va
revenir et je vais deuxième question
c'est d'ailleurs est-ce que sur foot est
roi skf 5,5 outre ces questions et vous
pensez que les jouets f5 tolère pas en
fait ouais tu veux 4 quand même d'un
visuellement finalement c'est fou pris 3
quand même hélas hélas et notre foi
question est-ce que fouler cette attaque
le pion est à 5 d'abord menace de faire
à 4 chasser le fou escg ef 5 je touche à
rien et je vais avance au centre est à 5
mai à 5 juste si je peux faire à 3 way
you lie sa tournée
[Musique]
ça c'est la manière la plus logique avec
les blancs avec les noirs en fait un 4 x
2 tours 4 j'aime bien parce que ça me
donne les cases noires quand même de
l'autre en revenant à six noms bref des
8 ou quoi même à terme oui peut-être
mais je me pose la question est-ce que
je peux jouer à 4 tonnes et que les
banques belges avaient bien fixer les
pions sur blanc nul à l'efficace blanche
mais bon prendre soin des rassemblements
concept on va voir mais bon je parierais
sur les cinq cas assez sur abc un accès
trop logique pour qu'ils soient pas
jouées ce que tu gagnes un temps sur le
fou et tu veux mettre ton fort inquiète
au four b3 et l'a peut-être fou bessette
un taureau d un peu de temps de lui
d'autres scènes ordinaires
cinq médias quoi sur m6 en fait sur les
histoires que le clou je n'aime pas en
fait je lance il n'est pas stupide store
l'hiver fois après là je peux plus le
comprendre alors la fuite
bon puis tour c'est un fou ces cinq
demandes et chic à moitié kureishi avant
les autres en petit et non du coup on va
appuyer joueurs enfin on peut alterner
monde est content par à coups la triste
quand même c est cool de voir les
joueurs je trouve pas l'échiquier
miniature * 02/06 sur le téléphone ou je
sais pas en fait ça va dépendre les
gentils sont chez eux ou sur le
téléphone vous savez prendre la taille
de l'écran du téléphone chance d'écouter
sur ordi tu vois très bien quand tu es
sur téléphone ça dépend du téléphone à
mon avis va investir un écran plus grand
du coup bref je passe
ouais ça joue mais c'est pas mal je sais
pas pourquoi ils étaient en pleurs sur
sa chaise soit alarme madrid je faisais
une line up de combat tranquille à sa
paire de fou il va défendre son pion
central passé donc c'est cool
ils avaient ils avaient vraiment l'air
pas bien sur sa chaise sur tout ça en
fait nous inquiéter parce qu'il a
tellement l'air mal en fait ça si on se
refait un petit tour des stades il
paraît que né pouvait bien de presque 90
ch à dessus face à la vision qu'on avait
mais il ne vous écoute dame sith c'est
ça cette fois ci c'est pas lui qui a
planté la préparer il est mal autant
mais à la pause j'ai passé le mot
revient cela soit rejoué la poudre
blanche qui tourne c'est pas faux
bref on a trois bon pourquoi pas il
développe de faire deux sanguins moment
ensemble avantage plan quand même ça non
bon tu veux te bouffe à 5 on va être
comme ça le truc pour un tournoi surtout
à faire des tours c'est un des choses
comme un bel avantage espace au centre
et aly zoulfecar en 1h40 à celle inverse
alors oui c'est lui qui marchent pas
c'est caruana qui a replanté une prépa
ça semble étonnant hein toute façon
devoir dinger l'otan est planté la prépa
etc les noirs mais on a du coup pas
surprenant et dépôts à bellevue la wii
et s'arrêtent souvent ce qu'on avait dit
des quatre lots vers la position l'autre
alphonse évident pour y [ __ ] et va
faire torah c'est un évent de saddam
découvert paris va rentrer partout il va
gagner en une heure trente connus pour
aller très très vite ouais je jouais vie
il a encore une heure 34 bon la bonne
nouvelle c'est que maxime il a encore
1,9 contre dépôt oui mais de façon on
n'est pas aux façons ce sera dit que
j'avais annoncé pour l'utilitaire que
des nuls et badstuber celui-là tu penses
qu'ils tendent pas avec maxime avec les
blancs non je pense qu'il va non mais il
va tenter si maxime lui donne
l'opportunité de monter oui mais je
n'arrive à rien joué deux il va pas
jouer une greenwald h4 ou ce genre de
choses je le vois plus jouer un truc
tranquille je sais ce qui va jouer
contre maxime je suis empoisonné l'âge
d'or fin peut-être avec un test avec ses
mémoires un truc comme ça il peut
chercher un petit avantage je sais pas
où mais pas un truc qui joue l'autre en
chambre jay hill a aucun atteint ces
poursuites ont su le faire tu perds des
candidats c'est pour ça que je dis mais
nul tu es plutôt bien il ya quand même à
trois défaites consécutives sur le pion
empoisonné tu dis joue une petite
variante tests de mémoire dans une
variante flénu la couleur claire tu
lances et puis tu vois je pense qu'il va
faire ça à l'epo contre contre maxime
mais si jamais être tout maxime avec un
point d'avancé qu'ils jugent jamais joué
pour faire quoi oui oui tu joueras pas
quelque chose double tranchant c'est
c'est ce que je voulais dire
mais vu si maxime vous bien l'ouverture
on a vu conquérir la belle ouverture
elle a fait bouger 4 souvenir laissé
tout fait ça sera du tout le tournoi je
pense ouais on avait tellement qu'hier
c'était un peu bâclé redon en finale
deux tours à lait venus se battre avec
celle qu ils voient rappelés suivant ce
que fait caruana aussi voilà peut-être
après il aura besoin d'un manga ou d'un
truc la vision commune non clairement
c'est son son plan de jeu et donc maxime
maxi nasa n'a pas joué non plus de
réflexion écoute je me sens très c'est
je le vois un verre d'eau et j'arrive
est très stressé à la détresse toi à ce
que des cinq ans risquent pas de tomber
chez mv albert non comme on vient de le
voir maxime peut facilement le protéger
trois fois ce pion et il n'est pas si
simple à gagner on avait vu b5 four b3
fou bessette tour d un tour des huit
on avait vu ce genre de variantes du fou
g5 apsys fouet trois cavaliers prend des
cinq serait envisageable mais y aurait
dû tout reprendre et 5 fu prend des 5 et
tour des 1 c'est le genre de variantes
problématique avec ce fou qui est cloué
le long de sa diagonale qui peut pas
prendre la dame
il est fou et une fois par par le fou
sur la diagonale et les coûts et une
deuxième fois sur la colonne donc il se
fait cueillir et surfe ou g5 qui
attaquent la tour si la tour vient en
dix-sept palais blanc pourrait jouer un
coup peut-être comme dame g4 pour m pour
mettre la pression sur la colonne g sur
la tour 17 éventuellement et se damne
des positions très compliqué à prendre
cavaliers prend fou prend fou prend fut
f6 la dame ne peut pas prendre ce
caillou dame prend 17 il ya des attaques
le long de la colonne jay et après j'ai
six on pourrait déjà joué fou prend 1,5
il n'ya pas d'un prince un conte adam
prend 17
donc ce sont des variantes complexe nous
évidemment cette de l'ordinateur pour
pour les trouver parce que sinon il
faudrait que qu'on soit concentré autant
que les joueurs pour pouvoir les voir
mais mais en gros en gros c'est le type
d'idées des blancs c'est de jouer très
dynamiquement
pour pour créer d'autres attaques et que
lorsque les noirs réussissent à
s'emparer du bio minc les blancs et des
menaces trop forte sur un autre côté de
l'échiquier pour un minima le récupérer
donc on va
on va voir alors le pion quelque part il
est en danger mais c'est un danger
contrôlait quoi parmi eux aussi les
noirs veulent le prendre les normes vont
se retrouver en danger autre part
on va
à voir ce qui se passe
est ce que les noirs ou un autre coup b5
probablement j'imagine que c'est pas le
seul coup candidats un coup comme f5
pourrait donner envie pour faire 4 mais
le problème c'est que les noirs n'ont
plus de fous de cases noires donc s'ils
en venaient pas de faire un coup genre à
4 6 ans venait à jouer eux quatre pour
mettre la pression sur le centre le truc
on va je vais faire un coup comme dame à
4 da me rend fou prend c'est qu'en
réalité il crée des trous sur cases
noires et et non plus de fous de cases
noires dont qui se retrouve avec le pion
les pions et le fou qui font double
emploi est il comme ils sont orphelins
du foot cases noires il se retrouve très
très faible sur cases noires et le pion
des avants serait donc très facilement
du coup f54 c'est pas un plan possible à
cause des pièces restantes côté noir
partant là le fou faut bien le
développer il peut pas l'en f5 qui peut
pas l'en g46 ven 17 il rebondit vers ces
six niveaux russie ce donc là encore
c'est pas une belle casse pour le fou
donc b5 semble vraiment être le coup
logique quand on chasse le fou le four
reculons mais le fou en baissse est
assez logique côté noir tour d un tour
des huit c'est logique aussi hélas le
fou g5 à pain à mon avis c'est ça la
position la position clé la position
critique à avoir et et à évaluer mais
savait qu'après tour 17 le petit alger
katla c'est sympa fab pendant que tu
faisais ta petite pause juste d'alger
kahn qui faisait plaisir sur le tour des
simples quidams g4 avec l'idée surprise
prise prise d'avoir le petit fauve si ce
qui est assez joli qu'il faut sur le
cloud and surgery sur la surcharge de la
dame
je situe et j'ai si tu prend 1,5 le gars
était mieux l'été mieux vaut donc ça
c'est le problème pour les noirs
maintenant à régler
c'est complexe ans comme position et
après ok b5
il pouvait troubler cette tournée et si
on fait pas de tour des huit ont fait le
tour s'est vite ouais
complexe fait ça joue tout sur le fait
ce que le fou réussit à chasser la dame
ou pas du mérite oui grec
étendu toucher 5 ceux ci forment un sert
d'abri aux six tours à des huit ans on
n'a pas regardé pour sa 3ds vous g5 pour
17 d'america thouet mais là il ya f5
peut-être fait retour à des 8
ok subtil c'est important encore est ce
assez subtil ça tu peux te tromper bah
ouais bien sûr tout ça va être logique
de mettre l'autre tour pour faire tour à
ses huit colonnes ouverte pour ce tour
mais quand tu calcules son sacre était
life à chaque fois mais ce que tu veux
faire tu rêves des huit tours à ses 8 tu
calcules tu vois ok ball z il doit
trouver ça et que ça mais si on y trouve
en annexe i trouv pa vous serez pas trop
à quoi c'est pas sûr qu'ils trouvent
c'est pas sûr du tout qu'ils trouvent et
réfléchie en tout cas après d'un f3
c'est vraiment le moment clé de la
partie fable j'ai l'impression que dans
les six sept coups qui viennent la
partie va complètement se décanter soit
ça va rentrer dans quelque chose de
vraiment égales soit un peu mieux vaut
mieux voir les blancs bien mieux de lyon
à voir mais c'est là que ça se décide
c'est là le moment critique de la partie
[Musique]
on va voir on voit pas en fait on voit
pas ce qui nous fait mal guérie
il est concentré et maintenant il est
vraiment à fond dans la partie je pense
qu'il est complètement hors préparation
à présent elle a plutôt l'air d'être
concentré de calculer les besoins
énormes - quelque chose là bas j'ai
l'argent qu'il était inquiet de se
prendre quelque chose et puis du coup le
fait que maxime ralentissent ou quoi ça
l'a rassuré le c5 lui a fait peur il a
clairement été inquiet de quelque chose
pourquoi
mon coup c'est pas mauvais coup dans
l'absolu mais tu perds un temps quelque
part sans b5 pas traîné pour faire
baisser sa faiblesse à toi et qu'en tu
fais b5 tu le fais avec tempo tu force
de pousser 4 à bouger or sur b6 les
blancs on peut mettre en place leur set
up pour défendre le pion des cinq
facilement et voilà après après
peut-être c'est pas mal parce que c'est
vrai que tu contrôles plus de cases mais
pour moi le groupe logic cb 5 mais c'est
pas idiot de six mois et si ça paraît de
garder les cases aura donc ça buzze
entendre ça ferait ça peut être une
option avec 5 où elle est vraiment déjà
foutu je crois me dont 3 s'affale une
éponge truc nombre se fait déchirer mais
je comprends pas ça va tu verras tu
mettrais en 2002 c'est pareil quoi
cheikh n'a pas eu un coup difficile des
blancs pour l'instant non non c'est
victoire très facile pour le moment
ça c'est intéressant et en cette fin le
faut roche sa partie des éliminées
favorable on va pas le faire là dessus
très fin à la fuite
c'est la partie des joueurs éliminés à
et odile guérin il a pris le pion à 5
rebonds 5 contres truc on sait pas mais
tu as roanne elle a quand même d'être
clair il a l'air d'être tellement affûté
pour ce tournoi tellement près toutes
les parties soient pas assez sérieux qui
s'est fait un nom qui se prépare il fait
pas et qu'on va sur internet fait pas
les machins 1 est ce que j'allais dire
que j'allais en venir là c'est en fait
car on a tu vois que lui il a il n'a pas
joué du tout les toits sur internet il a
rien fait mais qu'est ce qu'il a l'air
prêt pour cet événement l'odeur d'asti
de la poubelle jaune brio et oui il a il
manque un peu de mais en fait c'est
bizarre j'ai un fond qu'il faut quand
même moins bien à son prime alors oui
dans le milieu du jeu oui d'accord avec
toi ça y est super bien préparé il est
super sérieux il c'est impressionnant il
croit il donne tout l'abnégation dans
tout ça c'est parfait il tient le choc
physiquement il est bien les parties
longues il est bien mais avant il dit
clinique est là en fait ils ratent des
trucs déjà tata steel et l'aï raté un
peu des parties il faut les gagner
on a vu on a grand maxime il a fini par
gagner en passant par une potion nul
complètement nul alors que bon il doit
gagner et bayer contre agrexco et il a
plus un quand même quoi donc entre
crainte et une opportunité comme ça
d'habitude y faisait donc
donc voilà ça me fait penser que il a
des petites défaillances mais en tout
cas dans l'attitude la préparation tout
ça il est très bien quoi il est vraiment
très très près comme guy rien les deux
les deux tu sens qu'ils sont quand même
une vieille dame thierry gehring droite
a l'impression qu'ils sont vraiment très
très près un baril à progresser du
propos ouais
cris a réfléchi fais toi et sa tour dans
sa main c'est un truc que je fais
souvent aussi quand jouer de prendre une
pièce et de la faire tourner en france
faut que sous une tour bon ça va être
une conception là pour le moment mais à
gérer bien le faire et qu'une tour 1res
et usa avec le doigt et eu le temps non
plus de chess com/fr kiêu fipa voilà à
tanger regarder de quoi ça parle
attend il regarde tu l'as vu banon je
suis au tchad qui dit à jour rien si la
mairie tall blacks fait 900 kg et que
aguerris fait 60 kg tout mouillé on
comprend pourquoi des fouilles de
parties à il nous fait quoi là aniche 1
c'est lent parce que si tu regardes que
la position et que t'as pas vu le
langage corporel de maxime a vanté très
confiant bah tu te dis il peut il peut
craquer lire ici tu as vu le langage
corporel tu dit maxim lapierre
il a joué dans bf3 au hasard il clique
il a cliqué ouais non mais je crois
d'ailleurs samedi c'est quand même
extraordinaire
je vais toujours en tête pour le
marathon oil a l'air pas mal et m'ont
guérie
c'est de courir aussi un peu tanné
points qui se balade pas mal passé par 6
par année pour en réalité il a dépensé
combien de temps je reviens tu attends
attends mais encore idée il ya encore
non mais ça c'est pire en pire la
pression c'est quoi
j'arrivais ici stora sérieuses un
effectif cinq thèmes poney à chico est
direct même pas tu réfléchis quoi à
l'étang et surtout elle fit l'ordinateur
propose quoi tient à l'étranger cette
femme ne sera pas jouer ça c'est très
beau déjà fou prend c'est quoi nommé 3g
le cadre ce que tu prends sur un très
beau très beau et on croit prend 4 c'est
beau mes tripes
alors ça c'est très probable en partie
en fait ouais mais bon ça ça demande
beaucoup mais qui sait et reprendre
cette dame b3 qui veut dire viande 17 tu
penses à planter des découvertes et
laissera pas jouer ça je pense pas que
dans une telle position
après fo avaient fui tu t'en bête
affaire qui avait plongé cette personne
au bout du truc
non mais tu vois je vois plus le tour
prend dès 8 ans prend des 8 et 5 ou
quelque chose autour d un même ses 7 g
sync afin de positionner
audi propose cavaillon huit mois avec
food émis depuis déjà deux doigts dans
aia bref 5 vraiment à deux doigts
oui mon fouillis 4 août mais bon c'est
peut-être marcy wauquiez projet c'est
vrai qu'il est beau c'est peut-être mais
pau va pas le voir mais l'autre va le
voir il va pas faire faux et puis de
santé en bella surtout preuve 5 et
perdre moi je pense que s'il faut à
figeac et étrangers cette je joue quand
même
voilà messieurs à faire faux problème 5
d'un bref cinq fois autant abandonner
j'ai pas dû apprendre qu'il réponde
enfin pour moi en fait ça c'est déjà
abandon de houston donc j'espérais avoir
fait une faute de calcul sur quel projet
7 avoir raté un truc resterait sur
maxime les amis je sais pas pourquoi les
gens le chat par le parti a rangé à
tanner peau du numéro quatre mondial
devenu champion de russie en titre à
l'excès inco complètement hors de forme
le fait que les pôles le piétine
c'est pas non plus une surprise oui
surtout que j'aime bien inquiéter de
genre de joueur ouais non mais en fait
c'est arrangé ils auraient déjà perdu à
l'aller quoi ils seront fille de fait
nul
il n'est plus en plus à montrer son arme
we never de fait perdre plus d'un contre
maxime enfin fait perdre pas que ça mais
je veux dire
il a été bien contents de la garder en
surprises et que là peut-être ça se
passe mieux
donc non non ça s'est arrangé pour
arranger la les stars ange tu fais pas
une si grosse star en kiosque ou en plus
oui ni non ça tu peux faire ce que tout
le monde va dire mais c'est tellement
grotesque mais mais peu importe un ta
range pas la partie une étoile et blanc
ou de toute façon il est quasiment sûr
de gagner tu joues une hache dorff
dans le truck calais avec les peaux qui
a les noirs et compliqué puis d'autres
comme d'hab
mais je luis il a dit c'est la première
fois derrière d'après et vlad l'histoire
à des candidats qui a pas de shu
je vous prends évidemment j'aurais
dernière fois en 2010
shu ouais bon jour toulon c'est histoire
tout non c'est toi tu ne sais pas mais
tu ne fais pas partie de tout le monde
[Musique]
maria la lie à pas de loup l'a cette
fois ci ça ce poste pour max beaucoup
tout ça va on verra d'ici là je vous
prends f5 à l'iccn quoi mais j'aimais ça
autant abandonner
on va voir mais oui oui c'est très bien
et c'est complètement raide non c'est
pas beau la paire de fouilles est
toujours au centre il ya la pression
mais bon en attendant on avait dit on
verra comment ça le tour en terminant
femmes évidemment monde avait parlé d'un
dépôt
qui craquent sous pression qui peut être
mal est tous là pour le moment ces trois
premières rondes si la gagne encore une
fois s'est pas fait mais alors auront
été géré de main de maître un cerf qui
l'a fait ce qu'il était venu faire sur 3
2 nuls sans trop se fatiguer une
victoire après on verra
mais après on verra pour l'instant et
son iphone
j'ai vraiment ce qu'il est venu faire
mais en fait je sais pas mais je n'ai
jamais trouvé si faible
psychologiquement juste en fait des fois
il joue mal mais je suis prêt surtout
psychologiquement un mois je crois je
crois pas que son probable soit craquer
sous pression je crois que son problème
c'est que dès qui perd la confiance il
peut tilt cela sent que c'est un joueur
qui a besoin d'être en confiance mais
j'ai pas l'impression que ce soit ça tu
racontes il a dû gagner à jérusalem et
puis la finale ils devaient gagner aussi
ouais il a gagné les deux donc la
deuxième lycée pour la méthode ou la cie
loi il était patron l'otan non non
j'étais fonds servent à quoi
donc je sais pas j'ai pas eu cette
impression de lui je sais pas eh bien je
vois que des foyers tournoi et quand il
veut et quand il a gagné le championnat
de russie l'appareil
il n'a pas du tout tremblait pas mais
j'ai l'impression qui peut passer à
travers parfois genre complètement
ça me rappelle ce n'est pas le grand
chef tour à paris où il pouvait
rattraper maximon blitz et il a commencé
à perdre absolument toutes les parties
je suis l'été leader il a commencé à
enchaîner les défaites elle finira qu'un
sur cinq points sur six mais c'est plus
il commence à perdre une partie puis
puis il n'arrive pas à arrêter les
hémorragies perdre une partie ça tu as
besoin s'il en perd unis perdent deux
parties et perdre un tournoi terminé
dernier arrêté les échecs ouvrir un bar
enfin j'en sais rien moi de venir
streamer venir streamer on dit oui c'est
à paris ouais moi j'ai pu
impression ça c'est parfois il s'éteint
à s'aguerrissent fait longtemps qui
réfléchit ça sent le coup de merde
ballon s'il faut trouver il faut trouver
trois des huit toiles dsk
laisse gagner n'est peau non comme on
vient de le dire ça c'est pas le cas
dans ce tournoi il n'y a pas de mec
chelou qu'elle ça donne pas envie
quelque 100 live roule à linverse
maintenant je suis bien sûr quand je
vois ça que je n'ai pas envie du tout
dialogue qui demande la référence pour
voir le fauteuil de lvmh pote votre des
truc similaire ou sinon on va voir la
marque des dauphins est peut-être un
titre je penche et deux phares et ça se
trouve ça fait qu'on est si malade
allait si mal anduze adorent voir sur
sim allende on connaît pas en fait on
s'est renseigné de talent on savait pas
où un dauphin avec un logo tout c'est
une intéressante ses ventes emporté
russe donc enfin livraison ce qu'on peut
avoir le nom des mecs chelou non moi je
connais quelques-uns et même chez nous
dont villa de parme et je ne donnerai
pas de nom il y en a pas ici
guy qui est en train de de perdre à la
course la fesci beaucoup après ses
problèmes en une vision très important
dans fait pas ce qu'on a dit c'est ça la
partie va jouer dans les cinq-six qu
admirer ce coup va décider des cinq six
coups que tu vas jouer derrière donc
c'est à l'est le pion bb6 tu as décision
lourde de conséquence il a hésité
longtemps probablement entre b6 et b 5
cases noires salaire correct comme cool
je trouvais ça regrettait le couple
logique mais film one case battu joucas
blanche cases noires ouais t'as les
pions sur noir le piano plus l'option
faut aussi tu gagnes option fois à six
faces et peut-être même sali denner
pleutre éclairé ans maxime qui repart se
reconcentre il est en baisse
à l'aller ce qui va tomber là
probablement fab
du coup de chaud en justice rassier jeu
par écrit ça y est il repart et très
longiligne oui
pas assez là c'est aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il a pris l'option scratch comme on
avait concédé hier dans le stream très
fort le scratch gagnée
ça y est reparti sur la concentration
après ce coup b6 alors qu'est ce qui
peut avoir comme option fab bas autour
du tour des impasses que tu surprotège
champions est comme ça surtout à 6 tu
peux ne pas échanger les fust a promis
ils ont foulé cette et puis battu deux
prouvent qu'ils n'ont en fait pas j'ai
cinq faux trop songer 5 mai
ouais je dise passe pas mal de choses
mais ça joue bien je me demande si
commentaires sont à mon sens que tu es
un peu mieux entre guillemets avec les
blancs que tu as une position plus
agréable mais comment est-ce que tu
presses contre avance un plan en fait si
on pouvait avoir un cavalier à la place
de ce fou de théâtre de la dame tout ce
qu'on veut je n'arrive pas à voir qu'on
chasse la dame ce que la dame c'est un
mauvais bloqueurs parce qu'on peut le
chasser généralement mes jeux
non mais
4 daran l'impression que c'est un
ighirri je vois pas c'est un genre de
truc c'est comme dans les dessins animés
c'était un cauchemar quel personnage et
ça y est c qui marche un peu comme ça ça
y est tout droit et qui qui qui fait
délit c'est pas ça juste m'a choquée
j'ai regardé le le label j ai je une
ligne pas c'est quoi
si tu as le voir non mais désolé de te
couper mais c'est 6 pts 6 passes en
arrière plan ellis et stikeman c'est
vrai que c'est assez tête il me fait
penser à tu connais bob l'eponge ouais
mais toi tu est le poulpe même je vais
pas bien le plus voilà doublé mais je me
demande s'il bouge pas comme ça le
groupe c avec ses petites pattes de
poule b x et y passe victor lossent
länder manhwa peut-être tué c'est normal
car oui carlos mais peut-être sundermann
ou carlos mais on revient au gardien
mais ça c'est pour ça que tu peux tu
peux pas avancer il ya un grand nombre
de matchs on le voit passer le hic
tu vas voir il va advanced ndar man ray
boucle voilà plus lui-même b'rith
naturel et eelv a fait et fait son choix
il va il va retourner de l'autre côté
c'est sûr même si on regarde ses coûts
dans l'est c'est terrible il va y
arriver
900 / tu vas voir
il va passer et hyperactif regarde
regarde il a des jambes immenses en vrai
chaque année tu as vu passe comme ça
comme adriana quoi j'ai vraiment
l'impression de d'un personnage de
dessin animé mais cérences länder man je
pense tu vois ce que tu vois ce qu'il
sait c'est normal mais non je te montre
attentive aux raisons à 2 secondes et
ivresse et ça en fait
le nordmann et
harvest est un film d'horreur en fait il
est très costaud comme non apparemment
pas vraiment mais mais tu vas h à la
gare oui
ouais mais y'a des gens qui ont il ya un
air non on peut importe on s'est un peu
on a un peu à divaguer mais à part ça
joue beaucoup en même temps ça je vous
parie en même temps ce n'est pas la
partie la plus de belges ou un fouet
donc cette dame et du rachat c'est en
réalité c'est les blancs une position
plus confortable essayons de comprendre
comment faire pour progresser juste
bêtement
ouais non mais en fait tu peux te
retrouver pas si bien ses positions
bizarres et tu peux trouver mal même
cette position de l'échiquier c'est quoi
la ja foncé 1 il ya le fond c'est un ben
me pose la question mais ce que fois ci
c'est ce qui compte surtout g5
il en fut prend mais qui allez prends je
regarde m 35
je suis assez drôle quand on fait un
truc bizarre c'est que talent fou de
cases noires tu as une case noire à
libérer pour être mieux et tu arrives
pas la toucher il va te faire un petit
peu comme caruana contrat avec c'est une
couille rcf 6,5 pas je peux montrer
juste pour schématiser je fais des coûts
qui servent à rien vraiment qu'ils
servent à rien fait pour schématiser il
peut te mettre cette structure là les
motifs de bloquer toutes et toutes les
cases noires et ils bloquent le fou et
il joue avec le carré contre le fou le
bret double tour sur des marais mais oui
dont il fois ci ça me fait pas plaisir
ben moi je ferais vraiment tour d un
autre visuellement les blancs sont mieux
visuellement mais quand on réfléchit son
magazine on a l'impression que celle
inverse
il faut à 6 voire comme ce vin tapas
four b3 et je pense qu'il est bilingue
toi tu peux aussi te fait un petit tour
prends tu essayais de paraître par
hectare
mehrez week end 6 satam finalement n'est
pas si mal placé non plus ouais ok mais
je pense tour d'un c'est important pour
moi j'ai pas une façon de quasiment dix
fois à 6h10 b3 ou là mais ça j'aurais
tellement pas envie bonjour même juste
ça tu es assises d'ailleurs c'est
bizarre soit bien pour le mans
peut-être c'est bien concrètement pour
une région une raison que j'ignore ce
que tu vas faire dame prend il ya des
six c'est fini mais aucun nom mais je
peux comprendre
du coup c'est chaud mais je peux
comprendre que les blancs puissent être
mieux ici
oui mais d'accord mais tout revient du
coup c'est important parce que tu as ton
des 6 à la fin pour une autre raison a
dit une prophylaxie contre fois ci ça
pour l arbitre il sait tous qu après b3
alors dit que les blancs sont beaucoup
mieux
le stream et 3 soit parfois trop si oui
et quand tu fais fou prend pions prend
le truc c'est que la dame protège la
casa trois tours d un bien tourner un
bien j'attendais juste à fouler 3 mais
en fait très peur b36 autour des infos
vsat messassi le comprends ça peut être
un piège de ou fin parfaite même sans le
comprendre retour d un arrêt j'ai envie
de le faire tu veux dire par là c'est
que si fait tourner un que l'autre pense
que fois ci ce four b3 c'est plutôt en
sa faveur et qu' en fait sur x 6 le coup
c'est b3 et que les blancs sont mieux ce
sera un piège de ouf
ouais donc il continue à regarder sa
fiancée incroyable à chaque manche et
passifs et en en drama the way autour d
un faux bessette peut-être voici c'est
complètement idiot et peut-être fou g5 à
ce moment là mais
on sait pas trop le plan à suivre pour
les blancs même mais j'en avais dix fois
ci son héros en fait je
plus ambitieux je sais pas ce qu'il va
faire là bas se fout genre cf6 en reste
pas au final en faveur des noirs souvent
à 4 tout de même fait le point tous les
cinq ont fait part d un faux message pas
un cadre certes hors des huit baies 3par
ouais mais maintenant il ya plus de
combines non je pense pas simple d'être
vraiment bon coup en vrai bravo je sais
plus qui paraîtra dans le château bien
bulbes et 5 peut-être aussi parce que il
défaut à six parce que moins de cases
noires plusieurs contrôles la casse et 5
tout ça en fait tu te dis que messi tu
vu ses cases noires tu juste pour
bloquer les cases noires et côté dépôt
juste pour faire un petit comme la
partie semblait proche de ça n'a pas
joué depuis d'un problème à une épaule
il va juste le kart mais la vie minutes
ouais il s'est juste cartonné la vie
minimum je peux comprendre après que je
t'aime à l'otan contre un bus qui peut
faire c'est pareil je suis ou deux mais
oui ça pue et les autres caruana
un car on n'a pas les temps c'est pas le
temps bon c'est bon fautrel 106 ma
position est très complexe juste ordi
damas de est énorme avantage blanc faim
énorme +0 8 quoi c'est pas des très bons
résultats ainsi caruana et les peaux
s'impose
oui mon époux gagne c'est juste
prévisible caruana on espérer que non
quoi bien entendu mais c'est pas une
bonne chose si les 200 vols parce qu'il
va falloir vraiment scorer de ouf
bon c'est une heure 22 pour cameron à
1h01 pour ding oui donc c'est pas c'est
pas alarmant non non mais tu va pas
falloir que né peau et caruana smet a
scoré les deux ah bah non c'est
inquiétant j'ai un seul mec qui se corse
un peu chiant parce que eux ils vont
avoir leur confrontation directe aussi
un moment donné oui au cercle cea-leti
se battent engagement à s'assurer de
kibale autres c'est tout de suite finie
parce que le départage particulier
caruana maxime est en faveur de karwan
armés skema moeurs donné pomax qu'à
l'inversé dépose donc en fait un quart
ouanna qui a un demi point devant c'est
à dire qu'il faut marquer un point de
plus que lui sur clermont il faudra
gagner et que caruana perdre pour le
dépasser donc ouais c'est pas vraiment
une bonne nouvelle que j'ai envie de
faire plus qu'un roi n'a que des pots
puisque dépôt j'espère encore le battre
avec les noirs en fait qu'ils allaient
nord maxi moralez noir comptent mais pau
oui c'est toujours possible ajustement
des taux ils doivent juste pour zéro
risque vingt mille à l'heure n'est pas
aux côtés d'annie moi je pense qu'il a
les noirs par contre ça fait vraiment
peur je pense que non je sais plus parce
que caruana vraiment tout envoyer le
show plein fouet les noms caruana il
fait très très peur en vrai imaginez
ce truc qu'il était gagnant gagne et il
gagne aujourd'hui bombe et d'abandons
d'animaux non mais genre tu leur voix
plus mais il est où le temps vient dans
l'ouverture fin c'est incroyable caruana
est tout le temps plein dans l'ouverture
s'est encore deuxième fois avec les
blancs sortie d'ouverture il est mieux
avec les noirs ils égalisent
systématiquement servant actuellement le
meilleur le joueur le mieux préparés du
circuit même si on dit guy impression
les ouvertures je crois qu'à roanne etc
allez encore un peu au dessus nature
d'un joueur
on l'attendait un jouet je crois bien
joué le coup de marloux mieux les
maximes et ce qui peut se planter et
faire x 6 ça peut toujours même mais
bien le tour des individus fois ci sont
assez bien prophylaxie un dépôt
en famille chat c'est déjà très bien
du coup une épaule il va faire rage
jeudi nous allons dépose sa stratégie
déterminée rtc battre l'autre
aujourd'hui c'est nul partout un temps
réel wayne on impose sa strate elle est
vraiment clair et net
donc je vois vraiment aller dans un pion
empoisonné contre maxime wave a fait un
show où une petite poule b saint cloud
un petit truc
t'as pas trop risqué une âge d'or fund
chevaux mais oui un test de mémoire pour
que l'epo en fait
parti d'aujourd'hui était tellement
importante quand ils pensent pas fait
tout ça se rate le tout la sera donné
pour repose sur la victoire aujourd'hui
contre est excellent comme il n'a pas le
choix que de le battre est si le bats
pas tu es soutenu me mets tout astral et
qui ne sommes pas sous la grosse ou sous
pression dépôt il répond présent
parce que là aujourd'hui c'est à
vraiment la pression gagné une partie
c'est jamais facile hein aux échecs même
contrat loire qui a 100 points l'eau
demande doit mieux se passe comme toi tu
joues contre avec à 23,80 non 24 24
autres avec à 24 21 je gagnais griffon
sur commande ou pas bon je me sens
j'espère gagner mais bon on va bien
favori mais il rendra bien à paris non
là clairement quand tu vois dit celle de
l'ex où les lots non on verra ce que ça
donne par par la suite mais c'est assez
impressionnant les pots pour le moment
et maxime le tour des armes et on verra
ce qui va faire sur fouet cette quel est
le plan sa pendule
un problème après qu'un dd des problèmes
de pendule à tellement de gens qui
regardent les pendules que j'ai une fois
j'ai commenté pendant deux trois minutes
les secondes qui déroulait le visa d'or
non mais je sais pas comme il adore
regarder qaïda pour liquider rouge et
bon assez ça doit être le truc le plus
intéressant votre ça va être les
pendules qu à fin mai 7e et je trouve
que c'est là le coup intéressant de
maxime oui eh bien je dirais aussi fou
que ça je de bons coups l'un et l'autre
mais dire que là c'est le carrefour pour
maxime je trouve le p6 b5 c'est le
carrefour de guéry et jeux 5e à 2
minutes 50 tu rends tu compte 48 est ce
que tu penses que maxime a assez de
temps là avec 57 minutes pour terminer
cette partie irak après là quand même
dix buts d'avancé sur gris ça ça peut
vraiment faire espérance pas bien oui
c'est 10 minutes limites peuvent tout
changer
minutes c'est toute une vie non mais tu
as raison le prochain coup de maxime il
important parce que il ya fort qu'il
trouve un plan ou de mad love cases
noires comment agencer les pions et
c'est pas ça m'embête je vois pas de
plan évident parce que bon les noms
a priori ils vont faire tour des huit
vont encore de mettre une charge sur il
faut g5 tu as c'est notre coup après
officie son comprenait pas trop
d'ailleurs est-ce que fabre un jour j'en
rêve six fois jusqu'à tg5 ça peut je
parle pas dans cette position précise
mais est-ce que ce cette construction
face au fou peut être gênante problème
c'est la dame paraître f3 donc il sera
jamais mort ouais et pas en fait tu
aurais changer l'autre fou peut-être ça
va leur foi ci souffrent qu'ils aillent
prendre
ok ça peut-être ça va je sais pas
pouvoir mais avec le foot que je mange
des blanches jamais je ferais trop vite
sur casse blanche
à tout prendre des haches 4 et donc f6
ma foi c'est pas mal flash quatre
peut-être fait un rouage suite un coup
comme ça tout enlève tu fais toi c'est
toi et des huit mais moi ce que
j'aimerais bien réussir à comprendre
quels plans de mac ça reste comme active
ou jouer avec du damage saint cloud et 3
tourne autour des tours c'est un tour à
tour h3 c'est peut-être pour ça et si
c'est pas sûr en fait c'était plus
solide à cap sciences est tabou ce qui
t'arrive compris met les pendules encore
enrichie en plus
f 6 c pas logique pour moi je vais faire
tourner vite mais peut-être je sais pas
ce qu'il a joué c'est la position
d'accord il a fait le fou g5 et il s'est
levé il est parti maxime à la france
soit bien à la france
à bab amro part on y croit fab
aujourd'hui quand même hein
malgré la fouille de parties piégé que
hocine donné à maxime
il nous fait qu'une bonne partie à ce
serait beau de donner des feuilles de
partie avec les geeks ou 1 2 3 4 5 6 à 8
tu payes tu ne comprends plus faye deux
parties truquées maisons de ministres
travaillent
il a bien géré il d'ailleurs thierry
concentrés aux médias
yves qui trouvent qu'on veut c'est bien
sympa l'art dramatique pour lui mauvais
tours s'est vite
gicquel 6 pourquoi pas est ce que le 6
mai je suis pas je remets les calmes en
grand un petit peu on analyse est
maintenant annoncé à ses les sommes
jouées à une partie d'échecs ça se joue
fabien même temps qu'il réfléchit xmco
bon c'est pas bien de tomber un jour
serait en fait on peut aller voir
ailleurs c'est un bon gars il a fléchi à
les déjouer
damien qui en c4 c'est tellement
cartonné l'an dernier la mairie en c4 ok
ils ne pouvaient ça sorte mba obame et
d'un gros fauteuils aussi mais je pense
c'est évident à ses réserves petits
fauteuils bleus un peu dégueulasse pour
pour avec scène connaît qu'un genre de
une broderie joue un donald on brûle ses
rangs pas le fauteuil du winner à
mathieu payet candidats avec un fauteuil
bleu pareil non très clairement on est
poli c'est déjà ce que je n'aime pas
qu'on y réfléchisse que très clairement
il sait ce qu'il va faire et leurs
cheveux tempo là même il fait part de
beaufays viens et je joue thème poids et
ses jeux tempo et réfléchi
temp am happy happy cash ou quoi je
repars politique de la chaise vide est
lui aussi a bien un qui n'est pour bien
faire son retour mais c'est beau à
elvire par marcher à fond il est très
heureux quoi pour servir encore 17
minutes
heureusement qu'il avait tué riccio
qu'un homme c'est bien pour son
expérience
je le vois pas rejouer d'autres qu'on
est dans sa vie en fait mais leur
affaire a tant qu'elle n'est pas ton qui
participent et ça te fait grandir cette
envie d'arrêter les échecs aux siens ça
dépend tu sais qu'il sera pas champion
du monde où tu peux te dire bon bois où
tu tentes à faire ta carrière dans le
top 100 mondial études bas et que ça à t
d être dans le top 50 du coût t'aurais
pas fait ou je sais trés il se fait
tellement marcher dessus
mais bon c'est le petit jeune du tournoi
aussi vous faut se faire les dents puis
qui sait ça se trouve en fait ça a aidé
à progresser vraiment il sera bon
appareil prend quand même très très cher
à le pauvre
c'est terrible je pense que les blancs
il va jusqu'à car elles étaient cinq à
offusquer des cinq sous la menace un
beauf ou g2 télévisa ville et que c'est
un peu un peu dur après jarre qui prend
b2 c qui est des cinq direct où on
retournera maxime ouais j'y réfléchis
juste sur un 2 secondes et la fage fois
jusqu'à 3 je choisis aussi soit être en
leur sein je sais pas en fait je jouais
avec f5 qu'ils pensent mais le problème
c'est que si tu fais f54 tu donnes les
cases noires oui je sais pas c'est un
coût qui me fait espérer fab h6 et les
vannes de l'ordi qui monte un peu
d'ailleurs et les vals de l'ordi qui
monte un peu après ce coup peut-être mal
joué par le joueur néerlandais dans
maison et si je suis pas convaincu qu'un
hic sur f5 ya fouet cette boum un nom
qui fait
la m5 ya pas faire maintenant car je
pense qu'il veut pas de shopping si tu
le laisses en observons sur un fils sert
à quoi du coup tu tu enlèves les options
de f6 armée du coup le fou n'ont
quasiment déjà choisi son camp il va
plus revenir en d2b 4 où déjà il aime tu
t'es affaiblie cet engrenage de la
toussaint
ça peut devenir intéressant pour max
ouais non mais
il y à fond mais ça l'est pour aller
pour les choses différentes j'ai vu que
en conférence de presse comme ça on
reparle dans le chat gris tout qui
comprend pas dit que c'est n'importe
quoi je les aurais pas la même chose
mais je le comprends enfin la
visuellement pas tout le monde qui nous
demandait 1 qu'est ce que c'est que ça
en vrai nom mais en soi joseba c'est
ridicule c'est la même chose oui niger
ce truc de chasse différentes moi
personnellement je trouve ça assez
ridicule bon c'est rigolo parce que
c'est rigolo mais en vrai c'est ridicule
mais c'est comme si tu faisais jouer
tenues différentes tu m'intrigues est à
taille ouais mec que tu prends ta
couleur autour c'est rigolo le le
premier jour oui mais en vrai c'est
ridicule falla quand tu regardes temps
avec un des grands de chaises des petits
soient qu'est ce que c'est que ça en
fait
pour preuve ce que je disais non ça
anecdotique oui et non enfin oui c'est
anecdotique ça change rien
et non ce n'est pas anecdotique c'est
que c'est encore une bizarrerie des
échecs
au bout d'un moment tu commenceront à
l'indic filles 1 mardi t'as pas les
mêmes chez moi je sais pas où il en est
un en bon ben il ya trop de face a fait
beaucoup quoi mais aussi qu'ils se
trouvaient tous à un moment donné c'est
juste que s'accumulent quoi or en
ridicule qui passent huit heures de jeu
autant être bien ben oui enfin je sais
pas tu as une chaise à une chaise vingt
mamans soit elles sont au mieux un jeu
wii fit dans tous les toits du monde que
je vois tu vas tu as la même si
visuellement c'est vrai que c'est
bizarre quoi puis surtout que la chaise
ordinateur je trouve ça très moche la
chaise de geri je la trouve très moche
en soit j'allais chaise avec des
roulettes
on croit que tu es venu au boulot quoi
je peux voir des belles chaises quoi je
sais pas ça me vaut moins que pour un
peu se ressembler quoi tu elles
pourraient être convoquées le 5 ou le
plus en est une qui est bleu tonnes qui
est vers saint jean noiret dans le même
style au moins quoi quitte à être
différente mais dans le dans le même
style le plus aux réalités des choses
c'est vraiment au moins le même coloris
ou away le même esprit quoi comme une
gamme
ça va pas du tout ensemble ces
territoires monieux danse parvenu
en tout cas j'y crois bien pour maxime
faut toujours se dire que c'est clair
qu'il va gagner ou quoi c'est
sympathique comme position assise sans
plus à 6 avec fois h4 tempo et sûrs
réfléchit c'est mauvais signe pour
guérir les gérants quand tu as quand
même si sur fois je capte à une suite
quand même mais que c'est un coup à 6,5
ou qui crée une menace donc soit il fait
fou et trois en gros soit ffu h4 bonfoh
h 4 c'est le coup le plus logique
non mais en fait il est venu rejoindre
poitiers tours des huit voies de fait tu
fais tu ici c'est normalement oui mais
je voulais dire soit tu repars voir la
ceinture par par la mef logique c'est de
faire foi h4 exhaustif est fou et 3 je
peux comprendre que tu refasses cuistots
se ressaisit la vie oui mais le maintien
de te faire flasher 4 c'est le coup de
fil logique pourquoi tu réfléchis tu
joues quelque part il faut bien
réfléchir une heure douce sur un coucou
il veut quoi l'enfant s'est rendu c'est
très fin qui s'agrippent oui surtout
qu'en plus il ya quatre possibilités
pour la vfr vaf jeudi bientôt savoir
qu'il faut pas réfléchir autant il
changera d'avis great food
il va très bien de jouer après avec ses
trois minutes à la pendule qu'erding bon
complique
1 comme positions complexes et u10 est
né pauvre ou juste 5 et l'autre
réfléchir sur alex enhco vraiment dans
le dur pour voir bon mais maxime est ce
que ça commencerais pas à se dessiner
sur on partirait pas sur une petite
pression là une petite pression est quoi
pour le joueur français puis en hongrie
le plus qu'une 34 minutes et coûte ses
pas et notes mais largement plus quoi
bah ouais il avait il avait 48 je crois
avant de commencer cette série où 49 ça
fait déjà et 15 minutes de réflexion à
100,00 mais bien regarder les pendules
tu vois c'est une grande réflexion déjà
pour ces petits coups là il lui reste 22
coups à jouer en 30 minutes
ça commence à rentrer dans une dose
intéressante pour maxime et et surtout
il sait pas clairement comment continuer
ça qui rassure non mais c'est pas
évident on nous dira clairement goffin
par planck là j'ai oublié pub à taper
sur les doigts par rennes trois minutes
alors six minutes là qui vont partir de
sujets à savoir un petit peu réfléchir
les pubs qui partent et guiry qui
réfléchit il ya guy dubois plus j'ai
fait autre chose mon jeu parce qu'il
fait il sera installe finalement j'ai
peut-être pas bien pris la bonne chaise
[Musique]
et à fébé cinq mamans hu
voilà c'est conceptuel il veut comme le
fou peut plus venir sur cette diagonale
là il se dire qu'il peut s'affaiblir
la bonne nouvelle c'est que l'ordi des
tests mais peut-être juste alors
peut-être temps fait voir on va on va
les remettre en grand écran là pour voir
un peu le merlus très bon ouais c'est
sûr être un peu choqué par le coup j'ai
rarement vu un crucifix faible dans ma
vie
tu sais fabien tel coup comme b5 c'est
quand même assez spécial
parce qu'on
au 40e donc dans 22 coups il y aura il y
aura il y aura 50 minutes et puis 61
milliards 15 minutes et chaque coup qui
joue il ya une 15 secondes il va faire
quoi il va faire faux bond à l'étroit
ici c'est le coup loggia protéger mais
je n'en lis qu'on peut tenter food et 3
pour dames f5 mur a g6 non non et a5
j'imagine d'imaginer b4 alors dit d'un
avantage énorme tracer un tu sais qu'ils
jouent très bien ses positions les gens
qu'on connaît ça ça va revenir très mûr
passé qui est vraiment fort dans cette
position là si on peut accéder
il est terrible on vous le poussez quoi
une grue is your way to c'est un pion il
joue ça très bien mais tu vois ça me
rassure parce que mieux rtas et maxime
bon c'est pas tout à fait le même style
mais c'est le même esprit qui nous
intéresse les maximes brasse et le mi6
moi je dis ça je dis rien ça fait 1 40
là sur l'ordi ça fait 1 40 mo fab qui
rit qui vient de faire de la merde à
paris qu'il fait qui fait du gros caca
il est parti marcher au il en train de
regarder les sponsors il ne marche plus
ils vont arriver là le dauphin qui a des
dents qui poussent annoncé pas lui et
non gary marsh ses carreaux n'avait pas
bien vu que kaspersky était sponsor
qu'est ce que ce sens maintenant dans
les bacs si on regarde ça enlève la
baisse
bon alors c'est ça qui assiste à une
tête de coups de merde regarde il ne
comprend pas je n'ai jamais vu un tel
coup
de quoi ça parle
j'avais bien écouter vlad avant mise à
part faire quelques tweets c'est vrai
que
il n'est pas vraiment pas si fort que ça
bon là c'est en train de bien se passer
pour maxime et petit siège à roulettes
regardiez revient regard gars à
retrouver ça y est on regarde moi sa
hausse est terminée et il haïssait il a
vu le coût de merde la très très
clairement il a vu le coup de mer de
regarde ça y est ça y est c'est parti
les amis la faute de guiry tant attendu
est arrivé
oh ça c'est ça c'est ses notes refuser
ça le décollage est imminent
la france allait il se moucher un petit
peu à limoges toi oui toi bien sur
l'échiquier editora doute un petit peu
c'est pierre maintenant il va recycler
un petit peu a doublé sa dame là comme
elle va devoir bouger bientôt au c'est
bien joué ça se moucher c'est un coup un
coup très puissante ubaye un petit peu
peut-être éternuer aussi ne naît pas
trop la main devant sa bouche
voilà ça se voit voilà ça fait des tests
pcr peu l'oreille un petit peu de
partout pour être bien sûr et ça va
partir en calcul je la sens très bien la
fab joue un petit mur va initier un mur
allez la france
parcequ'en
l'ordi c'est juste dam des trois alors
attends c'est hyper simple en plus tu
attaques le pion et comment il le défend
son pion j'ai quand même pas quand il le
défend en fait c'est ça qui est terrible
je ne comprends même pas son idée en
fait pour le mot est ce que ces dames 6
dame prend dacca et c5 dame prend des
cinq car il me semblait 3 c'est ça son
idée ok c'est ça son idée prend b3 tour
avait 8 ans à son idée de pouvoir
reprendre deux pions peut-être ok mais
de ça tu veux la jouer longtemps à totti
mais c'est de tenir ou je pense et je
vois pas d'autres cette dame détroit
pascal papé quatre noms ne tourne
partout
oui puis toujours une rue à tout ça je
sais pas je pensais vraiment ça son idée
je vois pas d'autre idée c'est 32 1 me
apprendre la dame parce que ça faisait
le monde d'un désastre mais on était
quand même mieux avec les blancs
d'avions plus tôt et je pense que
objectivement ça va se tenir avec les
noirs mais bon ouais mais c'est un choix
l'autre c'est pape l'autre c'est
vraiment un gros con responsable quoi tu
te sens pas la situation était obligé de
donner un pion aux dettes souveraines
finale alors que tu avais ça avant vos
propres s il a super bien analyser et
mis un bon un bon je m'en dire un bon
diagnostic à mon jugement sur la
position
bravo à lui mais l'étrange d'étonnant
soupçonnant il faut être engins vraiment
ce que cette position elle semble à peu
près force et en plus un puisque dame
détroit ça semble vraiment cavaliers six
matches à part annoncé s'être annoncés
pour faire baisser un qui a six qui est
cette non encaissé cinq dames b5 et p3
dame b 3 je suis enfin de bonnes chances
de garde moi je passais gagnant je pense
c'est genre sur 1 20 % de chances de
gagner 80 % nul ou quelque chose comme
ça mais c'est énorme je ne veux plus
perdre même plus
enfin juste ça dans tous les cas tu as 0
% de chance deux défaites et enfin même
1,3070 c'est énorme
ouais non mais mauvaise phase de guy
riba écoute c'est dire on prend et dames
de ces quarts et dc5 faire la même chose
et d'un grand baie saint paul il ya
consacrons paye cash 604 ouais bon ben
si c'est pas si simple à faire mais bon
tu fais ci sera chez toi mais les
jusqu'au boutistes a pas de plan clair
c'est un peu angoissant
alors qui veut faire d'un mandat
d'amener 3 mais ça changerait en fait
oui mais si c'est pour venir mais après
mijoux maxime la joute à me2 mais ça ça
revient la même position que bourse
d'autres encore mieux du coup dans la
veine option bassin peut-être un peu
moins fort sans quoi mais ceccarelli ces
cinq dames pro b c'est la même avant moi
doit pas d'âme b6 ou je sais pas quoi et
d'en prendre cinq mois c'est réglé ça va
venir et j'avais l'air content quoi
revoir
ouais coûte ça se passe plutôt bien là
il ya eu le petit moment de flottement
parce qu'on sait pas à quoi s'attendre
on comprend pas ce que fait guéri femmes
mais c'est plutôt pas mal quand on a 30
ans en fouillant un peu dans le bon sens
mais enfin je leur mets je leur mette en
vente écran là où il est je vais essayer
de laisser quelque chose sur guiry fait
vrai coup trois caméras sur chaque
partie
non mais ça manque de caméra tu viens
son choix de joueurs il est grand temps
nous bah pourquoi pas face et quand même
l'équivalent d'une demi finale de
championnat du monde peut quand même
avoir champ contrechamp quand on voit la
ja que ya que quatre caméras tu peux
quand même en avoir douze fois je sais
pas plus surtout que ces caméras fixes
c'est pas très dur a fixé à fixer mais
j'aimerais bien avoir une caméra way un
champ contre champ mais je pense qu'il
est pas content il sera bien voir sa
tête en fait c'est ce que me l'on a
c'est terrible ils ont les fastes gamme
bon ouais c'est terrible on les a pas
elles sont ou du coup les caraïbes
en fait ça très dur temps mais trois
quoi mais nous on les a pas bon c'est
déjà mieux que rien donc
très calmes sur la pendule aussi
encourageant pour être bien sûr les
propose qu'ils essaient 5 pouces et deux
en fait dans le chatt coquet on n'a pas
du tout pensé pourquoi paul lignon
je crois que c'est leur dit mais moi
j'aurais fait un premier 5 1 je suis
d'accord avec toi fab
surtout que c'est maxime et que les
blancs à la france n'ont n'a pas on n'a
pas accès aux autres caméras les amis
mais je peux essayer de demander pour la
prochaine ronde après jour de repos
parce qu'on fait quand même plus de vue
que donc peut-être que commencer dès la
primeur de la fifa je pense un peu c'est
beau le touran il suffit il était
beaucoup suivi à mon avis qu'en france
en fait c'est le seul film qui
s'intéresse
on est les seuls j'ai pas les ruses la
raison il ya beaucoup de gens j'ai
regardé sur youtube tient par curiosité
à la france parce que c'est chez les
russes il doit y avoir du monde aussi en
vrai mais les rues sont plus youtube que
ce qu'en russie sont quand même un
joueur qui est favori et leader du
tournoi ça se passe en russie
non je relance c'est ici ah ouais ouais
non ils sont 4 198 rue ce filtre
engouement savez droit incroyable quand
même quand ils pensent et peut-être que
ça passe à la télé en russie possible
mais quand bien même sur internet ça me
paraît peu 500 personnes instruments
bons soins
c'est un pays quand même qui est deux
fois plus peuplés les gens sont
peut-être cinq fois c'est quand même
internaute pluton quoi donc
mais les gens plus ont beaucoup sur
internet surtout l'hiver ouais nan tu as
sur le streamer le plus connu en russie
la 1000 personnes il n'a pas les cas
mais la 1000 personnes et donc il ya peu
de gens qui suivent sa passe est à la
télé en russie présent sur la fidh en
russie au caire est donc en tout ils
sont six mille c'est très peu en fait r
c'est un pays c'est un pays d'échec
c'est quand même beaucoup plus de gens
qui jouent en russie et au russo
phonique en francophonie
mais j'aurai incomparable en plus ça se
joue en russie il ya un russe leader
fail devrait être d'une autre russe qui
participe
ouais non ils devraient être au minimum
entre 15 et 20 fois plus que nous sur
youtube 7000 m'ont même 7000 en fait
même cette nuit sur youtube c'est peu
c'est peu plus en plus généralement faut
regarder le stream qui a le plus de
personnes que les gens ils aiment bien
se connecter sur plusieurs choses à la
fois un bon jour il faudra en prendre le
stream qui a le plus de personnes alors
j'ai jamais compris c'est quoi l'intérêt
connecter à plusieurs trucs en même
temps j'aime bien oui mais en fait tu
veux pas tout et en même temps
ouais du coup il va faire quoi qu'il
arrive à faire b4 ben je sais pas si
farine issue d'un portrait d'un médecin
qu'on a vu non oui mais bon face
pourquoi perdre l'option jusque là il
réfléchit en gros là je crois que je
sais pas ce qu'il a raté mes salaires ça
une très maussade coup et ça va pas tu
veux que tu veux tu as une bonne
nouvelle je donne 75% de chances de
victoire maximum j'avais dit qu'il
fallait qu'on soit quarante mille
aujourd'hui pour que maxime gagne je
pense qu'à trente mille vu la position
mêmes troubles unsa peu soir c'est quand
même trente mille peuvent suffire ouais
même timide tu sais où et disques
caruana fait effet du fait de kaka
quelle journée fantastique mon fab bon
alors c'est soit les gars vous n'importe
quoi ah ok peut-être que c'est pas
terrible son coup je sais pas en fait on
n'est pas entré un peu sur musulmans
s'appelle erp sap a l'air à frapperait
oui bon du coup si bien si vous qu'il a
merdé en fait c'est 2,5 peut-être on
regarde juste alors mais je reviens de
toute épreuve avant le 5
du coup oui qui on dirait que damas et
deraa c'est le conte avait vu où il mais
bon sang pourquoi pas et après dans le
sens mais bon on est pour saya new quoi
énerver de me prendre cette page et
bosser finirait encore faut t'il finir
ok bon bah écoute c'est bien si car on
en devine pas cavalier dessine corps et
abandon est ce que tu attaques
lecavalier tu as damage cette dame a de
suite matin guy la jolie tu peux prendre
le flhv si non on est pauvre a gagné et
c'est pas grave ça y est c'est acté
non mais c'est pas parce qu'en fait
maxime lui sa stratégie c'est qui peut
soit 6 bat wang hao alexine qu il est
devant n'est pas ça qui va iris et bonus
ouais mais il y vraiment devant du crime
n'est pas w en fait à mais en fait ça va
peut-être changer que nippon va devoir
nous battre contre maxime ouais bah les
infos que maxime la gagne ça valait
vraiment importantes en réalité cette
partie maintenant dire qu'il faut pas
rater sa chance
là il peut vraiment se remettre dans le
tournoi les amis mais il faut les 30000
on est ici n'y aura pas de victoire
lippi orient c'est avec le cavalier moi
c'est catastrophique le kin ans mais il
va gagner c'est ça qu'il va donner une
pion aux puits
alors est ce que maintenant ah ben il va
prendre
c'est un peu la question qu'on a une
grosse pièce sur la prise du pion
bastien grosses pièces
j'avais un petit live et un footing quoi
mais un poutine sur l'a6 du pew un petit
net est aussi encore vu leurs lunettes
parc akwa iii le footing qui parle et
moi je mens saitama
tu connais c'est vrai une punchline
extraordinaire quand je connais pas la
nîmes mais je vais très très fort skyy
battrons avec juste un coup de poing en
fait n'importe qui en fait même les plus
forts et je suis un peu touché avant ah
oui mais ça le fait marrer c'est en fait
c'est un anime et manga comics ou en
fait jamais de suspense et de grimper
mais qui arrivent ils sont très méchants
tu pue ça c'est drôle mais tu t'attends
car il faudrait un suspense n'aura
jamais oui c'est ça en fait ils te font
croire qu'il ya un suspense je vois
bonbons c'est très drôle saitama le boss
pas c'est peut-être un peu maxime
aujourd'hui saitama
on va être maxime et un peu de suspense
super content car on a vu un peu de
monde n'est pas ils disent qu'ils
avaient fait 99 % à la cure à 6 lors il
a sorti une grosse prépa et une grosse
partie ses poches et ça ils le jugent
normal en fait aux qui finit ce n'est
pas bon mais je pense qu'il va finir
mais bon peu importe ce n'est pas le
problème en fait le truc c'est que
poussée de on peut concéder entend aussi
pas tu sais que vous c2t mieux mais
problème c'est qu'il ya juste un pur en
un face c'est pas possible ne pas le
prendre
on a vu caruana serait ultra est aussi
propre caruana parme qui a voulu faire
le malin et pas à prendre le pluriel il
ya trop de cas de figure enfin c'est un
peu comme tu sais que vous cédez dame b
5 si les deux sont bons mais tu sais
dans 90% des cas d'un pro b 5 sera le
coup alors ils adorent bouffer des pions
en plus maxime gérer ces les échecs
pourcentage satelis pourcentage à ses
échecs pourcentage le truc il ya plus de
pourcentage que la production soit bonne
combien de geek pour un saitama
webb a alors dit jon fossé de into in
twelve trois fois f2 mais honnêtement
qui va faire un match tu réfléchis à
fond pourquoi pas mais je sais pas
pourquoi essayer de former un grand b 5
enfin je me comprends si j'ai pas d'un
brevet 5 c'est un fou c'est de f3 falls
on comprend que c'est fort mais pourquoi
serait plus fort que damas prendrait 5
c'est grâce à un bon piont quoi ségolène
royal paye trop de suspens à qui et
prend b3 va suivre après je sais pas
s'il prendrait ou la dame ça déjà ça
c'est une question ça c'est une question
peut-être maxime c'est plus le cil
apprendre d'eux à d'ailleurs qui fixe un
peu le tour en a 8 et peut-être pour
beckham c5 tu vois maxime peut prendre
deux a en fait les deux décisions sont
plutôt bon a priori
est-ce que prend de behcet into fawcett
frei fuite on n'aura pas parlé du tout
ça non mais demain
ça aurait pu fin de la partie il
prendrait tu vois c'est plus moi
j'aurais pris de la dame et lui
apprendre de la la ces différences de
style tous les deux sont des binationaux
nokia pas à critiquer non ces questions
d'un branchement c'est plus classique
oui c'est un terme a baissé plus maxime
sa dynamique tout à cologne pour toi est
tour à tour peut-être serbe et quatre de
ses cinq doute une souligne t'évite
tourab et huit médailles il a pris
confiance
il enchaîne les coups vite on lit bien
qu'un autre maxime et on sait les coûts
qui ferait et le coup qu'on aurait fait
quoi c'est beau non
cette symbiose on a prouvé qu'on était
sûr et ab s'était tu apprends 1,5 c 98 %
et abctek m81 tellement dans son style
j'ai tout
qu'ils allaient gagner toujours dit
alors est-ce que le tweet de tout à
l'heure si gagnera fait une différence a
toujours je pense que sauf une brique
différence non tweet dif quoi le verbe à
à deux pages ce n'est pas drôle j'aime
pas du tout son humour et vlad
n'apprécie pas du tout l'humour de kiri
c'est beau quoi un des balcons barca ne
vendons pas la peau de guy avant de
l'avoir tué non mais c'est pas vendu
mais la juste on est mieux c'est clair
et net
bah je pense qu'on a là je pense qu'on
est en situation on a un jonah lomu
façade ighirri voilà et on est à vingt
mètres de la ligne d'en-but vont mal et
guiry aussi de f
le groupe et moi alors je pense que s'il
jonah lomu peut mettre un bon raffut sur
2,3 irrite déjà les sept autres prennent
peur quoi est juste lui va marquer comme
il faut un très beau symbole de de geri
face à un jonah lomu poussé bien dans
l'axé ighirri quoi alors la visionnant
tu pousses de conneries jonah lomu lens
à 200 joules quoi allait pas bien guéri
calmes non mais en fait un truc en plus
qui donne confiance c'est le genre le
coup le meilleur de mort dit cette dame
b 6 y'a plus rien je te bouffer je peux
sont bien que tu allais vraiment un truc
à faire
après sûrement il doit dire que tu vas
faire réussi ce qui va bleus et max
mandat est tenue une contreuse thing sur
internet 1 me dans cet esprit ou le pur
il a réussi en 17
mais en fait tu me manques c'est à dire
par là que prend notre offre un bien sûr
mais c'était juste pour pour te dire
qu'ils en aient tenu une un peu dans le
dans cet esprit là je vois il vient non
mais c'est pas fini
non mais gers et trouve avoir envie de
leur demander s'ils sont bien sûr
meilleur que j'ai vu maxime défendre
comme ça une fois je pensais que ça
allait super bien sûr très faible très
faible coût zéro point pour gryffondor
web et 8,1 et griffon d'or en sueur la
non vie font passer le coût que j'aurais
fait en fait donc de se fournir
non mais c'est ça me semble logique mais
j'étais surpris que le coup tordu
soudain b6 il est venu pour jouer contre
harry potter il est tombé sur dheune bol
d'or c'est pas de chance quand deux
hommes veulent tellement c'est tabou des
tabous de tabou à ces terribles
dumbledore et écoute il ya plus de 25
minutes
il a quand même 18 quoi faire nous ne
payons cap est simplement à défendre se
sentent plutôt bon plutôt bon pour
maxime temps ci
d'ordre
mais faire tout à fait 8 mais il voit
quoi je sais ce que je vais twitté ce
soir après cette défaite
[Musique]
j'échoue que cinq minutes dans la
pendule 13 coups joués je pense que si
maxime bagheri je twitte guy est hors
course quoi le contresens à contre sens
serait contre ce sens et d'agrosciences
et maxime shifter gilles thoreau maxime
shifter froggy à contresens fétiche de
tweets maintenant france et revin bref
des vitres contresens contresens aniche
d'un contresens à tanger trith
conscience contre
irrité à contre sens ma gamine
e
[Musique]
allez la st non non mais la chaise on
sait pas trop je suis très heureux
d'être un petit light master pro quoi
nous
les gars de chat avec le carnage et le
karma sionge tellement rien on est des
êtres humains comme dit maso on a envie
de jouer avant la honte ça change pour
nous on voit des trucs que tu veux
peuple l'a tellement de fois qu'on dit
karmakar bas puis en fait n'existe pas
du tout ce truc là ça n'existe pas une
légende
et oui le cours sur les lacets de maso
qui a fait le taf aujourd'hui 10 rimer
17 euros de l'est seront choqués par h67
et chaud quand vous irez elle a tant
mieux mais bon elle n'est pas encore
gagné celle là non mais on est bien là
vous france on nous dit tout ce à quoi
ça peut voit la ccc soit gain ce soit a
soit gain soit nul à perdre c'est
impossible mais bon on a enfin eu la
partie avec pression on est bien il va
aller on est heureux on va
car si elle va le faire c'est à dire
assez de faire fossile est de fous 17 et
là ok tout va bien c'est a remis le fou
pour bloquer l'avancée du pion tepa
bloqués comme un jambon là-bas dans ton
coin tu voudras le tout malgré neuf
sites szeged à nos missions pas fermer
quatre mois je les donne c'est 5
bêtement et je me dis même si tu prend
b2 les deux pions passé madame saison iv
change pas la dame je prends pas en fait
ce que tu fais ici
as-tu peut-être dame b 6 mais bon bah
vous leur dites pas qu'on est si c'est
dégueulasse à voir mais en fait comme
saddam c5 datant des buts si c'est pas
facile de sauter refuse de faire de
telles armes et moyens plus strict
blanche
ouais mais bon tu vas me faire tous
rêvent b8 in to b cathy maret de bkw
nouveau souffle à ce crime oui je sais
il aurait agi en fait jure que ça aurait
pu être logique de faire et fils direct
du coup un millier d'âmes prouver sa
page oui oui mais sinon il faut défendre
le frère du défunt
ouais tu défends le fou fait il aurait
voulu faire tour abyane et ils peuvent
pas il fait pékin gad weil peu émanant
d'un petit ses coups sûrs de mc5 tort
d'évoquer ouais mais bon c'est pas sorti
de l'auberge mais je peux te faire f 3
ok il te fait le dame ce que fout c'est
8 ouais mais bon moi je sais tout je
fais ta mais ces 5 g plus mon truc
et du coup ce que je voulais non mais
oui oui mais c'est juste pour expliquer
qu'en fait on est prêt à donner b2 pour
les deux pions pas essayer puisque cela
ils vont adam mobylette cécile chicault
projette shifter
par contre ne pas faire d si ça c'est
pas un shifter produit tout le foot
vient bloquer shifter protat avance
d'abord sur les branches sur cases
blanches sur la couleur du fou
voilà donc trois visites web et 4,6 pour
lesquelles j'aime bien et f3 f3 est bon
alors aujourd'hui faire de bêtises je
sais pas moi je suis pas à l'aise de jeu
en finale
ouais mais dans tous les cas à
philosophiquement tu viens de faire
tourbe et 8 pour refuser de le faire
oui tu arrives 6 pour refuser de le
faire et je te force à faire ce que tu
veux pas faire de tout à l'heure il se
trouve que c'est bon
bonne chance pas de chance mais en soit
je te force à faire ce que tu veux pas
faire quand même mais je pense que si
c'est un peu comme limoux
mais ce n'est pas dit qu'ils le
trouveront tu défends pas suffi qu'on va
te prendre dame ces cinq des six c'est
la mêlée qui avance quoi c'est pas du
tout je suis d'accord ouais mais gerber
4 alors d'être hyper fort c'est bien ce
que je dis bkc regarder ce genre méga
fort comme beaucoup c'est pas le coup
numéros lors d'un ordi fait tour à ses
seins mais b4 honnêtement pour trois
soirs pourquoi pas nous faire de ces 5
oui bien sûr mais je sais beaucoup avec
beckham je le sens bien parce que battre
tours allait bien ici pour être la
bouffe oui mais elle est bien c'est
aussi du coup et les autres tours on a
eu de l'éviter parce qu'ils font du coup
un an beaucoup de bons choix
b4g milliard dont toute façon donc c'est
cool mais disent que lille aime beaucoup
pk tu comprends et comprend beaucoup
mieux
une époque est en train de terminer
j'imagine je dois donner que ce soit
fini quoi mais qui a été 5 cette crise
de qualité pour tandem des deux tons
conseil à faire puis on prend d'arâches
fuite
oui ce mot quand même la junte la veut
dire aux français que cet abandon bombay
a quand même tourner - abandon 6 mai oui
et je me dis
sortira grosse partie digne
insupportable leur sont fournies deux
buts à l'aller ou au retour et contre
vaccine je vais faire tea party ce merde
pour être bien sûr quoi non mais
d'accord doit pas s'en prendre qu'à lui
même
il est mieux plutôt mieux après
l'ouverture vous pourrez choisir dans
les trucs hyper saïdi qui sert à
angélique oui l'a fait il là pour
pousser maxime époux bien là lights out
il va rentrer sans une partie de génie
année autres dépôts de pompe ou amis qui
feront que francis sino françaises a été
très heureux de des français quand même
fait bien a dit jean claude hêche en
côtes chinoises et pourquoi pas sino
françaises
du coup c'est plus répandue chanterai
mais du côté chantage sinon non parce
que c'est de ding qui a mis avec nous
donc c'est aussi nos francs un chinois
ça peut lui aussi je voudrais mais c'est
plutôt nous ben là c'est holding fading
lui se dit amitié sino françaises puis
avant lui dire si nos jours c'est joli
c'est quasiment gagnant pour elle ou pas
encore non c'est pas gagné c'est bien
quoi
c'est un contenu hl 50 gains on est bien
qu on ne suis pas dans les autres
journaux mais bien
france - attend jamais une petite pub va
partir mais plus que les américains ou
pas j'ai peur que non même avec le
reconnaît nous formate de la pub qu'est
ce qu'on peut lui faire f3 ok c'est bien
aussi un ces faux est de fous ses cinq
as tu sur le fait qu'ils aient pas vous
c'est vite à cause de ça mais il n'y a
pas de découvertes et tu prends ton
temps pour repartir
je resterai là ça replace le fou qui est
1 h 4 un peu hors jeu pardon je vis tu
vas il n'empêche les tours de 8 ou quoi
mais au moins s'il revient en f2 c 5 tu
déboulonne la dame deux des six et on
pille on peut commencer à aller de
l'avant
moi je les sens tellement la gagner
celle-là oui je pense qu'il va gagner
facilement fait voir on faisait dur à
défendre en fait un cahier maso qui
appelle sur les téléphones attendre et
kiffa temps je vais écrire je crois
qu'il est là je vais on peut le prendre
au chanteur ok il est dispo mais si je
te prends faut que je fasse le petit
truc technique à temps en temps tu en as
on en a pour une ou deux mini moquait
pas le temps de base aux arrivées façade
à chanter là ça va chanter oui je pense
la bonne ambiance
je pense que ça va chanter
simon des petites manips donc assise
joué par parle par le batave qui
attaquent la dame et à bouger cette dame
pour pourquoi pas comme ça non mais
l'idée c'est peut-être qu'il veut faire
fossé vite après du coup la dame doit
quand même resté plus ou moins la
défense de dessins qui franchit pas
pouvoir mais voilà et peut-être fou
s'est vite sous 17 pour essayer de tenir
le coup comme ça mais c'est quand même
pas enfin on va avancer avec les blancs
on va faire un petit fouet f2 on va
dégager la dame est le plus grand des
six ont essayé de recréer une tour on
sait cette mon travail damas 5 juin
mais donc oui on pourrait presque mais a
priori logique c'est évident mais ça se
passe vraiment très bien là cette partie
de moscou aux parfums je me sens bon
après si on n'a pas les 30000 soissons
il peut pas gagner quoi pour débloquer
la possibilité de gagner falloir être
30000 l'amazoo je pense qu'il va
confirmer
à 20 me dire qu'ils rendent peut-être
mais il arrive maso halle aux attentes
en a c'est sébastien qui nous entend les
gars un certain temps ça va ça se passe
bien et vous et c'est pas mal
aujourd'hui au succès lui tout à perdre
et tout de suite autour c'est un dogme
c'est celle née du coup les mines à tour
ses huit seul coup il a joué c'est pas
gagné encore non il fallait jouer à tour
ses huit fallait trouver ce tour s'est
vite il défend bien le bougre après 1
mais là on est très très bonne position
en fait on a si ce que je disais à
quelqu'un sur internet c'est que achi
c'est un coup incroyable quoi
catastrophe dans la paroisse zhuhai
chine stratégiquement tape à l'euro à
quoi ta structure veut que tu jouais si
c'est ton seul coup si tu joues f6 tu
t'en sors tu calcules tu trouves la
façon de faire nul et tu es tu fait nul
à chier c'est trop faible est ce que tu
peux plus jouer f6 tu es trop faible sur
les cases et du coup il est très mal
mais c'est pas encore marqué c'est
bizarre en fait la décision
là maintenant on a une position que
maxime peut jouer pendant six heures
avec gros avantage
non mais je pense qu'il va gagner et
maxime là dedans il est 100 fois plus
fort que geri même si l'autre y défend
bien
par contre victoire une fois que tu as
une position comme ça a vu le scénario
des candidats au koala la victoire est
quasi obligatoire
faut vraiment qu'ils la gagnent salah
away le problème c'est qu'il faut être
35000 quoi mais bon voilà c'est autre
chose même 30000 passerait il s'est à
peine on sent pas le soutien n'en sera
rien et peut-être offert le dragon ball
on est tous les mains
or l'énergie à mes amis à non mais le
gros le cam est menacée individuel que
tu veux dire le bonheur force mais ça
c'était vraiment la france c'est que ça
va arriver là ouais la france est là la
france est là la france est la france à
sortir du lot arrivé que font-ils au
boulot des roulés d'être là quoi ils
sont confinés pour une chose a été
confiné pour la première partie du
tournoi le continent aura duré un an
arrêté le 2 mai coïncidence je ne crois
pas ça avait commencé le jour des
candidats quatrième confinement enfin
fin novembre vous pouvez déjà noter dans
vos agendas
bah oui la source confirme
bon en tout cas c'est pas mal plus il ya
un gros truc c'est que ding et un
avantage stratégique monstre mais de la
colère car un wedding pollack hall est
en revanche n'est peau c'est solide
mentalement on l'attendait pas on
l'attendait pas aussi fort aujourd'hui
ouais mais il est quand même un peu en
mission n'en ai pas grand chose en face
aujourd'hui on va voir c'est une maxime
gagné cnppo gagne c'est parfait pour
fournis sont fous qui les gêne et bien
sûr maxime en plus il a le bon départage
contre contredit le pauvre et oye plage
et il ay leila il a il a joué trois mecs
sont au tilt donc green shoots amaigri
tout qu'aujourd'hui extraordinaire ores
et déjà plus que cinq minutes après
treize coups getxo congo l ex aequo
pierre 3 sur 3 dans la partie de la
partie de maxime aujourd'hui elle est
vraiment déterminé que ronaldo duré très
longtemps
on est en train de retrouver le ding là
de très très bien joué franchement
seeding l'arc au lac à roanne a battu la
prochaine fois qu'on le voit on lui
offre un petit cadeau français j'ai pas
bravo à nos jeunes ya un truc hein et la
partie pédagogique offert wedding
commercy ding ding ding il est
enfin c'est vraiment l'amitié
franco-chinoise 1 mais franchement il
fait plaisir le gars ont bien joué quoi
plein d'âme à 3 intéresse c'est le
auquel je pensais en vrai de sa petite
finale
ouais ça me prend à 3 béa et tu joues
sur des deux pions passer et tu lui
colle et une école j'adore les locaux
abandonnés injuste pour information
victoire officielle de nouveau mis hs
venu le moment
ouais donc là prêts à deux écoles soit
tu joues psif avec les noirs en jean
dame 17 ans tu cherches tu as finale non
non dame prend trois sapeurs ça c'est
sûr le seul truc c'est la règle fou de
couleur opposée -faute couleurs repose
et et cherche de situe à taxer takam de
grandes chances de faire mal donc tu
joues dame g6 pas grand-chose man down
est ici c'est à une pression sur les
cases blanches tour ces deux le fou 17
ans vis-à-vis de 3g 2 car entre-temps
des données allaient bien sûr mais en
fin d'année si c'est un coup plus
mordants que l'envoi d'une nouvelle
trilogie que judas manger si ça va tu
aimes pas mais ça paraît plus meilleures
chances pratique en fait lors des deux
tours des deux tours ces deux peut-être
peut-être faucheux déjà fou g3 sur fond
de justice pour ces deux camps même si
des web ont fait ça sont c'est le
meilleur ou après il faut essayer
d'organiser la poussée du pion blanc
d'une certaine façon plutôt fait rage
c'est la raison celle de l'exercice et
fort une telle vision stratégique en
fait c'est assez incroyable sans
calculer quoi le décès qu'a top j'ai
toutes les cases blanches john tu as
plus de quatre manches et cases noires
mais bon là irak ou critiques mais je
pense qu'il va jouer mais j'assiste à
leur foi après ce qu il est pas un peu
trop pleutres guéri pour un coup comme
dame g6 est-ce que sinon c'est pas les
limites de guiry là qu'on est en train
de toucher
je crois que les autres super comme un
agneau ouais mais ce que justement c'est
pas un agneau face à ce type n'est pas
un requin est plutôt dauphin en vost un
dauphin mais il essaye de se mettre une
armure regarde il a vu bien les dauphins
si mme allende quand il a marché à mon
avis il va pas faire d'alger 6 la mg6
d'hommes mais qu'à toi comme quelqu'un
dit dans le tchat ce moment en fait
c'est un état d'esprit
tourbes et 8,8 sur ces deux matches et
enfin j'essaie de bouger
tu cherches la fissure d'un ou quatre
jours d'anne decis retour après du coup
je suis d'accord avec toi d'amnésie
c'est logique tu as un pion plus devant
ton roi quelque part et du coup tu veux
jouer sur la taille du roi adverse
stratégiquement ça fait sens donc
voilà voir moment critique évidemment
maxime labarre chercher la finale il va
chasser la dame adverse sûrement de
plusieurs façons alors ce que fait guéri
mais là combien autant là il est il est
pas il est pas très bien plus guéri
bonne dose m 18 18 et il lui reste quand
même 15 courses et pas tant que ça oui
c'est très chaud ça va être très très
chaud on va donner il charge son niveau
1 qui fait une sorte de forteresse mais
il va pas voir comment en fait y'a pas
et sinon bah tu t'entends pas ton âme je
suis ou par par par défaut qua non mais
lvl par rapport à cette feuille de
partie c'est un tic dont il fait ça
depuis que sa vie d'un foirail qui est
où je les regardais jacquard essaie de
détruire mais j'avais vu autant le faire
ouais moi j'ai joué plein de fois il
adore faire ça il met des points sur les
i fait des trucs au temps au temps
autant le faire à céret karzaï qui l'a
fait une ou deux fois mais autant j'ai
jamais vu faire
par contre il est moi j'étais là au
début de la partie avait un truc qui le
gênait c'était pas le même siège qui a
est en fait le siège hier et peut-être
40 cm d'eau et enfin le début de la
partie et daisy tout petit en fait il
était tout petit il essayait de le
remonter
et en fait le truc marchait pas je
continue d'aller voir l'arbitré bon
c'est con parce que c'est vrai qu'il est
c'est pour ça qu'il ya le coussin c'est
pour ça qu'il joue sur le coussin en
gelant des choses il se faisait vivre
mes enfants mais si on fait via la
manette c'est à la machette qui s'est
mis sur la table pour chercher la
manette mais il est inapte il n'a pas la
tête quelqu'un qui a fait une grande
ampleur
coup il prendra trois droites non ouais
il va à droite ci va à droite à droite à
droite il percute à la reine et ma part
de faire une grande partie aujourd'hui
aniche fait que de la merde et il
regarde qu'eux à droite fait un
contresens par rapport à ton tweet c'est
génial oui mais ce que je dirai à
contresens quoi tu as à contresens
qu'est-ce qui nous regardent passer de
l'autre et on je l'aï lycées bloqués
fait une feinte de corps c'est comme au
foot tu fais exprès d'un côté qualifié
cadrage débordement
non mais là il part sur dame à trois je
te dis tout de suite non madame prend
1,3 impossible même pour toi tu perds
stratégiquement les deux pions j'ai
perdu je pense qu'elle est perdante mais
moi je le vois jouer dameron être alain
se donne 17 pleutres ouais mais h6 a
aussi paru être un coup absolument
impossible mons est blanchi c'est un
problème de compréhension mais la dame
prend 1,3 tu sais que tu veux rire ni
pau ne pas comprendre
par contre il est très mauvais en finale
et c'est un fantastique
c'est l'un des dents les deux meilleures
prépas au monde et joueurs actifs très
solide très bonne compréhension finale
cats à l'horizon d'investissement choisi
je comprends pas le coup c'est un dogme
mais si c'est incroyable fleurs il prend
au creusot pour aller au bout et b5
je sais pas moi j'essaie de comprendre
non mais attends il veut fief de m
et met en bessin quoi et tu te dire
qu'il va bloquer le pion sur des six des
six coups des cinq noms mais j'essaie de
comprendre ce qu'il fait mais plus tu
peux faire sur ce dessin qui fait quand
même 17 tombes reprend 17 damas a en
fait là c'est mort c'est bon tu te
prends le truc des 6 b 4 pouces et 5 au
tour 6 1 pour ces cinq sur cnbc à tous
et 5 c mort à ce qu'il a fait parce
qu'il faut pas faire en défense de flou
couleurs opposées jouer passif high food
for business à fabrice troll attaque
mais il se barre et retourne marché l'un
porte quoi non non il veut faire des six
dames 17 et je vais passif mais bon il
va se rendre
il aurait pu aller direct on décemment
voilà même si je n'étais pas assez
agressive
c'était bien joué de la part de maso
mais c'est tellement pas le style de
geri du coup coeur de 8,10 qui s'était
fois des six tu joues quoi tourner vite
jeté par dessus la tête explose pour ces
huit foule s'est s'incliné quoi
complètement fine et d'un noeud trois
tours à sa place c'est sûr que ça s'est
fini c'est sûr mais alors qu'on valide
et le point il va falloir arriver à
30000 maso n'ont plus besoin
hoffenheim envoyé un petit message il
admire aussi on est 23 mai risque est ce
qu'on écrase les américains ont ils sont
31 min quand ils ont réagi aujourd'hui
tu vas la colle et tu vas pouvoir si mon
garçon mais aussi digue
on peut faire un petit à un passage
éclair n'a pas bougé oh la la c'est
hyper excitant
voilà on est quand même très très bien
maso celle là elle ferait lorsque maxime
aujourd'hui il est tellement évidemment
motivé mais c'est vrai qu'on était face
à un ogre de prépa donc on savait pas
trop bas qui m'a dit que je faisais il
te faisais une dédicace avec c4 c5
c'est apparemment c'est un truc avec toi
assessing qu'aurait dit aussi quattro 6
une colle à paris ces think ouais
c'était dédicace pour toi c'est génial a
de la gueule d'après parti cécile côte
pas laisser ça en fait c'est ce qu'ils
sont 10 quand ils ont fait la ferai pas
ces quatre cécile cau c'est pour qu'elle
adopte un vieux après pas quoi je sais
pas stylet en main
c'est ainsi qu'aurait d'hakim haddi
surtout quand tu te dire tu vas sur le
chat tu dis bien ça c'est sûr mais on a
remarqué aussi qu'il y avait 1 1
un logo aussi mme allende c'était un
dauphin fait remarquer ouais si mal on
aussi parlantes c'est le sponsor
principal du tournoi
vu qu'on leur a fait de la pub rue
sponsor principal
j'ai deux les sièges télésiège je ne
sais pas si ma langue
j'irai prendre une photo pour les gens
qui sont intéressés si il y avait pas
mal de surmonter tout à l'air de
contresens panne de jonction je suis
très heureux de ma came rien aux faits
des chiffres au repos le shifter progrès
et d'envoyer des systèmes à 5 ça serait
jouable bond et si c'est tellement
logique quoi y'a pas d'autre groupe des
six là tu vas nous le pousser ce petit
pion à et pousse
du coup ils étaient état d'esprit on
était en forme aujourd'hui
évidemment ce que physiquement il est
bien malgré les après la fatigue mentale
qui a pu être compliqué voilà c'était çà
çà çà çà te remets
[Rires]
[Musique]
personne peut le canaliser l'abbé apbb
ça m a fait mal à y avait personne sur
la chaise regarde mais sont tous partis
est parti je suis trempé devrait aller
pousse le pouce bichon voilà quand même
céline et indécise b 4 pouces et 5
bonjour mais ils savent faire mais ça il
sait mais doit peut-être vérifier c'est
des trucs genre tour ces deux dames e2
j'en sais rien battus à 17 ans tu vas
quand même oui je regarde ces trucs là
non mais t'as le temps vérifier c'est de
tuer 20 dames à 5,28 ce que tu veux non
mais bien sûr mes joueurs c'est normal
de prendre son temps là c'est ça fait
des 4 as a vraiment bien berri et dont
il aura été dangereux dans ce tournoi si
l'hyper poche mais en fait tu guéri
c'est fini en fait s'il gagne
aujourd'hui il a un point de moins sur
maxime plus maximy l'oral
un match particulier fini et il reprend
et reprendre l avantage sur caruana donc
là on reviendrait un schéma intéressant
n'en reviendrez impôts schéma du début
de tournoi devrait livrer un truc disait
carson si maxime survie aux deux
premières en gros s'il avait fait un
ennemi sur 3 sur les trois premières il
des favoris du tournoi
après il y aura la grosse partie contre
l'épaule un ver qui sera peut-être
décisif qu finale mais juan la partie
avec les blancs avant puis celle après
donc c'est intéressant
et puis sur la toile à quatre dépôts
l'a6 et la capm mars et compte s'il
arrive à lui faire jouer un truc mais ya
réfléchi trois heures sais tu peux
vraiment gagner autant que jamais c'est
qui qui lui crée un karl scène je pense
car la scène comme le dit comme on
discute avant france il ya plein de
choses qu'on ne guérit dans le match
mais plus pour le côté extra sportifs
ouais voilà écrin écrin caruana carlson
je suis assez d'accord et ce que disait
vas tu sais corée caruana c'est le plus
gros adversaire pour lui et guéri je
pense juste qu'il se met tellement de
pression pour le match du championnat du
monde que mme avoir une surpression de
l'autre qui trollent non-stop
ça peut le faire tilter mais je pense
qu'après une épaule maxime il s'en fiche
à magnus moan et bien je vais vite et il
veut éviter les deux autres à hisser
vraiment que cannes
caruana il a la maturité là il est déjà
en fait ça ce que je disais on souffre
qui jouent moins bien que son prime dans
le jeu ils avaient juste préparé comme
un ouf c'est extraordinaire
là il joue pas bien mais c'est parce que
c'est à toi de reprise oui mais l'an
dernier combien je crois pas qu'il ait
si bien joué mais l'an dernier aux
candidats c'était un truc de ouf pour
lui enfin c'était trop compliqué quand
il a fait deux avions pour venir
tu te remets un tout petit peu en place
s'il va être super forme
dès que j'ai un moment qui suit pas il
ya des potions un petit truc qui un
grain de sable dans la mécanique caroit
nesc mais qu'il est bon il très sérieux
il fait tout bien qu'enfin le
comportement irréprochable quoi mais que
je sais pas enfin qui rira bien qui rira
le dernier
[Musique]
maso à contre sens qu'on n'était pas
contre sens et à repenser content je
suis un peu reposé c'est vrai que
physiquement c'est dur
la petite ristourne n'est pas gagné
encore ça là on est con ailleurs bien
hier ne peut plus faire les sushis
d'affilée beaucoup trop tard 1
on avait peur qu'il ait mal au ventre
que vous et sushi n'en fait pas du tout
ok on a pris les pelles mini est
aujourd'hui la solheim cas hyper bon
ainsi qu à celle assure ian khama qui
est exceptionnel tu crois un écran
spécial se souviennent kavaklidere vlad
m'a dit oui donc en temps je le pense je
viens il faudra qu'on aille chez pâquis
branges la solenca il souligné elle va
être content car il a écrit sur twitter
à baky il m'écrit c'est du 50-50 mais il
faut bien commencer ce tournoi médaille
écouter le prêt live quand j'ai décoré
lancé le tourner tout quand même pas de
baky c'est génial kwaï réseau y aller
écouter un petit peu ce qu'il faut faire
pour demain
non mais je suis d'accord parce qu'on
disait dans le pré live avec fav c'est
que maxime il avait besoin dans tous les
cas aujourd'hui de jouer une bonne
partie quoi qu'il en soit qui gagne qui
gagne pas il a besoin d'une bonne partie
pour rentrer dedans qua non mesdames à
vos frais maintenant faut la garder
chaud à la rigueur même une nulle
aujourd'hui en jouant bien vite fait il
peut vraiment gagner le tournoi encore
un il gagnait 2 p natif et nul n'est
pont et puis on parle le plus un nom
mais c'était vrai de jouer une partie
sans être depuis depuis sur 13 heures de
jeu il est à 12h40 en étant moins
ça ça ils avaient besoin de jouer une
partie pour pour rentrer pour se
détendre complètement être bien pour
après jour dans le jour de repos et pour
les quatre dernières quoi donc de toutes
façons le scénario sera positif
aujourd'hui après maintenant qu'on y est
et que guéri il est pas très très chaud
au temps de finir voilà il mérite que 5
du classement chat je peux remettre le
classement en un clic
alors ça c'est classement avant la
partie un niveau moindre à 6 ennemis
d'ailleurs mais on voit qu'en cas de
victoire maxime resterai coller aux
basques du joueur russe quoi et lun mer
départage particulier puisqu'il a battu
dans la phase aller donc en réalité il à
0,25 point de retard même pas donc voilà
rien n'est fait on verra t on de
classement à la fin du village on compte
les maisons à le vautour continue à
tourner autour de la partie c'est
terrible autour on y rit et pour les
lacets il ya une explication soit les
lacets tiennent aujourd'hui
seb je lui ai montré ce que j'ai montré
un rappel est battu à et ça ça
fonctionne de bordeaux et il doit être
très content maxime ouimet garçons ça
pousse
on joue à tempo toi c'est ça ouais voilà
n'importe quoi tu vraiment un contre
sens oui si ça fait ton blocus quoi mais
ça tient jamais a annoncé un possible ça
va exploser en plein vol pour sa part
fait un petit coup de damas cinq mois je
serai bien le pays 444 ait besoin loin
si vous préférez à 5 lautrec pour les
classes que pour éviter tout problème
fab et 4 vous et ghanéens qu'on se place
comme ça même en blitz henri tu fais de
tempo vegas ou c5
ouais
là c'est linéaire alors est ce que tu
peux faire un petit damas quatre pour
forcer flou sexistes bon je change pas
grand chose
je pense tu fais pas le malin en tu
joues mon petit mais quatre qui joue
scolaire avec 4 ou c5 et après tu vois
ça tu te perds ton plantu prépare pas
rupture mais bon je vais pas trop
compris le cas écrit dans le chatt
stratosphérique le plan d'amd 6 d'un v6
dame 10,5 dante 7
il peut il peut être des six à 17 des
événements du mauvais côté c'est vrai
que le plan est stratosphérique nf1 tus
a très très faim ne fournit plus en h4
cérébraux il a dans ces cinq avec b45
cessera tient ce week en plus quant à
l'abbé 4 7 5
il faut chercher la rupture après il va
jouer va préparer caf 4 ouais ouais pour
tout l'été entre ivoiriens et gh3 pour
mettre tes pulsions case blanche pour
être tranquille avec convoi et après
jour f4 et en fait tu mettras la dame en
d3 éventuellement b5 pour rendre un pion
est rentré en à cette date a plein de
choix déjà faut fixer le faut fixer le
truc est à prévoir et victoire dans la
philippe
qui écrivent ça hein qu'est le premier
que je fais quoi et oui c'est peut-être
une journée française aujourd'hui mon
maso c'est magnifique que oui annoncé en
plus ce jeu est une attaque de roger tu
commences à sa joie la fiq valverde
réagissent ils sont en pleine réaction
quoi réagit ce registre j'ai plutôt bien
joué damas quatre autres façons ça
change pas énorme un fou fou c6 d'un
match 4 tu vas réussir à placer ton et
c'est beau la victoire dans la fjkm
d'attenté sur sophie ciel bien mais qui
finit sur un twitter et on s'est
peut-être pour le damas quatre onces
époque ces agents qui avaient julien ans
de partout quoi on sait qu adama 4 ou 6
il a eu beau jouer aux dames à 5
peut-être qu'il est fort 7 à l'afp m
quatre positions et repartir en h4 non
il veut il veut partira vers le roi lion
du jeu on nous dit qu'il est en train de
totalement de choc je vais quand même
aller jeter un tout petit coup d'oeil
puisque c'est important cg44 c'est bon
j'ai pas vu la suite sur jet cut n'en
est pas du genre à n'importe quoi le
chat n'importe quoi je garde toujours un
grand couvent 10 4 sans jamais céder
random c'est no name du chat
fox news dames
català c'est ce que ce que j'avais
compris de dahra 4 mais ce qu'il a joué
d'ailleurs en fait ils laquelle plus de
km des pièces aux barques enfin quoi de
mieux qu'une dame qua non mais je
comprends en fait t'es tu veux faire b 4
après juste alors pas c'est adam
champmaillot un peu dubitatif mais ça me
paraît logique perso peut-être des
menaces de dams est éventuellement à une
poche bonjour mais j'aime bien un emploi
réservé ces cinq pays 4 au 8 8 ses
passifs qui l'envoie de foule pacifique
façon d'amener cet arrêt ce qui peut pas
tenter un touriste histoire j'ai six
adresses que aussi deuxième trio quatre
gars jouer gros ce qu'il ya quelqu'un
qui irait dans le chat un truc qui est
possible c'est que magnus où il pense
que sa défense mais c'est possible ça
défendent mais après tu mens et une
longue souffrance même nom ne pense pas
bonchamp ça veut peut-être ça en fait un
voeu 4s que maxime et haute en gagnant
ici que dingler à la non écoute est
vraiment avant un coût de l'abandon quoi
il a la même position que que caruana le
premier jour on peut mieux
ouais c'est mieux sans risque tu peux je
longtemps dirigé pas trop ce pas un
défenseur hors pair il va défendre c'est
pas un charlot mais il va faire c'est
pas très confortable et être annoncée
aux 4,5 sa vie des noirs cher que quand
tu faisais bekhadda fous ces cinq sur
quatre est peut-être fkt tu tu avais le
fou qui couvre trois de ses policiers
tadié trésor et sa dame des sept fils g4
justement
vinisud j'avais raison d'être le plus
est celle sur sur à l'afp quoi vivre et
un tout ce que tu veux que en environ
combien pour les rajouts de temps en au
29e coup ici reste dix coups à jouer
donc ça va ça va accélérer ouais ça va
jouer quand même assez vite là jusqu'au
40e et ça va être à mon avis une phase
importante fab ça pas trop temporisé ici
non même si maxime va être tentés de
garder la domination dirige j'imagine
qu'il va essayer de s'activer rapidement
donc ça veut dire du pouvoir le temps
d'être là le problème en fait c'est
qu'il n'a pas tout il aurait dû d'abord
joué h 3 avant de faire ce truc parce
que tu peux plus jouer d'alger 3
éventuellement sa tour j'ai 4 way du
coup comment il fait ça se baladent plus
agréable non c'est 1,4 me prend un tour
prend un coup bizarre peut-être comme
damage 3 qui peut être intéressant la
maj 3 bon après c'est pour entrer en
finale surtout c'est que la finale est
meilleur mais on peut pas assurer avec
des touches est pas un dieu
dommage cependant que j'ai changé pour
garder un bébé ça d'être excellents
essais à garder les bras non mais j'ai
pas super envie mais bon c'est à dire
des dames mais là il va y avoir du mal à
faire est ce pas sûr qu'ils soient
gagnantes un bon c'est pas sûr mais je
vais toujours peur moi c'est finalement
pas si on va voir ça sont maxime il va
jouer rapidement à temps je leur mets en
grand écran
la réputation des finales de votre corps
vous est nul je penche sur sa surface
est tellement sûr faire j'en faisais des
tours c'est tout sauf une
mais j'aime
la fin de match 3 l'ordi et dida machin
il va jouer la maxime je pense peut-être
qu'il va jouer trop bas j'ai pensé à un
moment que ça être une victoire balayé
quoi jean redirige ici crew enfin t'as
pas en faire un jeune homme en fait il
ne bronche de résistance est à y faire
mais comme maxime et autres jours sert
qu'il ait eu une absence vraiment clair
irie
et puis derrière en séries tout croyante
astrophysique et derrière en fait il
rejoint à 100% mais j'ai l'impression
que à ce niveau là ils ont tous cette
capacité ouais ils seront consentis pour
serra way to race est un ancien réussi à
laisser le mot hyper logique qu'on
attendait donc là évidemment quatre
patientes en cas de pareille complétera
toi je vais peut-être faire tour à ses
huit avants et de te dire je veux quatre
plus tard je sais pas moi c'est à trois
ça me sauve complètement parce que du
coup après je peux je peux mettre la
dame en g3 tranquillement je pense qu'il
faut il faut jeu 4 tout de suite pour
empêcher ces dames g3 un truc 308 8 h30
quatre ssd g3
tanger gars de plurien tv peur ou qui
donne sur la colonne c'est pas raciste
je repars en hausse il j'ai déjà dame
j'ai pas les trucs tactique là ya pas de
théâtre mais bon ok le cas de ces jeunes
est un tournoi je trouve c'est peut-être
la partie mais aux kiwis dom vayssette
débile toi aussi sont évidemment sa
personne regarde ou d'un ouvrage 3g h
fou 17 équatoriale bonne chance de lui
en blonde
je suis pas sûr ça mieux oui mes gains
votre fric et qu'une seul tour je ne
fais pas un franc pas un blocus sur 17
et au final il a quand même l'avancé de
ces psion est là un pion passé aussi
maintenant ça change des choses quand
même là il faut jouer à quatre en tout
cas il a tout fait pour que je sais pas
dring dring il réfléchi car il a plu
énormément de temps non il va ya voir
des imprécisions
ce sont là c'est sûr maxime lemieux même
si je vous dit tout et que je peux
peut-être moins clair il va essayer de
mettre la pression c'est là où il est le
meilleur
ce qu'on veut c'est une finale où il a
il a cet avantage normalement
l'avantagent disparaître à jamais là
sauf grosse bêtise elle bond à mach 4
ans qu'on voit quand même que c'était
pas oracle adam ici ne sert à rien il a
perdu tempo parce que dans tous les cas
si tu veux lutter contre j'ai deux tu
mets le four en g3 donc adam en h4 sert
à rien peut-être qu'ils leur billet le
plan tour 8 4 0 on a croisé rod a perdu
mais il n'aura pas à 0 ça arrive
quasiment jamais quasiment des forces
est en panique n'a plus de quoi jouer on
vient tranquillement sur les ricard
alors pour ça y est je pense pas que ça
soit fait il prend pas de décisions vers
l'avant c'est incroyable place ces
pièces mais doit vraiment pensé pourra
faire un blocus comme ça est-ce que là
là là je joue h 3 e 4 tours prend 1,4
dame j'ai trois tours 6,3 kg 6 donc je
bougeais madame est en fait après je
mets le fou en g3 idéalement quoi je
vais garder h5 mais à chaque au pire
enfin déjà je les adapte jackets detroit
ici déjà dam des trois ici pour jeffrey
page 4 des deux bords on va voir ça je
vous savez les amis il a salué pour ses
catcheurs poussé sur le torse et 8 onces
et 4 c'est la même idée
pas mal dans ces quatre je pense aux
accidentés ou quatre puits d'où les
tours
faire gaffe qu'un retour aux six tours
j'ai 6 ans je suis quand même très
étonné qu'il ait pas fait quatre mois
ici mais bon il doit penser pouvoir la
tenir comme ça aussi je vois bien jouer
pour ces quatre buts adif cissé il
oublie un peu son pion la fin ils
oublient un peu ces vagues de 6 à tous
ces cinq mois j'espère qu'on voulait
former en doublant rien du tout ça vous
fait des 6 4 ces cinq là t'as pas le
choix
le choix s'est fait reprendre et s'ils
saisissent leila ouaz 3 4 coupes atterri
là les complètement là la mesure de
l'adversaire
ces cas le pk tous ces cinq ans et qui
paraissait stabiliser un peu la position
avant d'attaquer quoi il a voulu faire
dans ma cave d'un match car il faut être
bon mais qui était peut-être un peu
artificielle dans cette position je
voulais c'est vite passé dommages qui
joue si vite après l'apama ce d'autant
plus peut-être pas être l'autre sous
pression des fois quand elle énerve
jouer vite
ouais ça détend non ça détend jouer un
coup bref ou c5 jouer ces 5 mai pour ces
4 je pense qu'il peut aussi voir
réaliser de fer b4g katché pas été
attaqué lui donne la main c'est fini il
ya plus d attaques foutront fouillons c5
c'est pas ton objectif je sais mais il
est peut-être à contresens en fait
contre sens
carmat fait quoi
or plus la même chose quoi ok et grichka
et d'une minute et l'autre fils adam
[Musique]
chasser bouge pas c'est peut-être
perdant c'est peut-être que c'est
n'importe quoi
une petite partie pour cornetto tête
deux pièces pour la dame un meilleur
aspect intéressant la bière spéciale
fabrique spécial curiosité on sait pas
trop quoi c'est chaud enfin je sais pas
vous dire combien pitt s'écroulait par
contre c'est sûr ingrid choper ride et
en c'est fini complètement et donc la
prochaine soit il fait mes gammes ohlins
wife nuls sans jouer oui je pense qu'il
a commencé à faire des temps d'échangés
à ce que ça sera nul sans jouer contre
maxime est la meilleure nouvelle c'est
que crèche ou gagne qu'il y croit encore
père difficile où je joue mal on vote un
homme de plus afin qu'ils appuient la
position juste un petit tour des stades
pour voir comme ça mais bon maxime et il
continue à presser un continental a
quand même son fion de plus vraiment un
truc déroulant ya perdu son avantage
farid belkahia tue vos cheveux une
oreille on se place entre cinq ans
ensemble at on fait des scènes en fait
dès 8 heures déjeuner 2004 fait que tu
pouvais pas faire ce plan est ce que tu
mettais une question tout de suite on
fatigue oui mais moins de temps pour
s'organiser pour 4 6 1 tour 8
maxime et encore seulement mbaye coutume
mais même si les noirs stabilise tu peux
quand même la gagner avec rappelant quoi
qu'il en soit je garde quand même ton
pions côté john j
après que c'est comment tu avances tu
vas devoir te réorganiser pour faire un
f4 donc une tour je sis tourne toujours
chiant enfin tu vas devoir temps pas de
george iii qu'enfin on était même coup
32e il reste gratuite en fait ce truc
c'est qu'il a mal placé son fils le
fouetter en f2 il était bien avec la
dame en a trois qui contrôle et des six
tu joues et ours et un pour commencer à
rentrer si le mec changer ses tours on
joue autour de 8 toi aussi tu avais
damas cinq dames 6 7 qui signé l'abandon
donc la b 4 pouces et 6 on imagine des
quatre pouces et six tours c'est un tour
assez ainsi le même tour vitia damas
cinq doigts que tes pièces sont bien
placés bien fait tout est harmonieux
dans ton position t2 foule tête à foot
en foot adapté de tour des grandes
monnaies au poste et là du coup en fait
à toutes ces pièces là nantes à une
courant sekkat influencé 5 in davantage
cap dans ta trois pièces qui étaient
bien placés qui deviennent mal placé
voilà plus d'harmonie vrai avantage 10
par l appât qui l'a fait disparu encore
davantage saab
une partie non mais là pas non
maintenant on a une partie en a une
partie où il faut qu'il se remette
dedans tout de suite parce qu'un mutile
vos gains oui oui oui tu fais faire
attention on a on peut avoir la règle
fukuda a opposé le premier qui attaquent
gagne la vue l'harmonie des pièces c'est
comme les noirs qu'ils vont menacer
l'attaqué ça peut aller très loin
je le dis tout de suite intégré au mode
attaque maximale et noir là je suis
confiant quant à mélanie blanc dure à
jouer la gagne
il faut jouer de manger si cela
related b5 ça serait une très bonne
nouvelle
on ne sent pas à l'abri de toute façon
il est il est un peu obligé d'attaquer
c'est là qu'on va voir s'il a vraiment
fait des progrès guéri non loin de là
mais bon tout
et pour que le suspense soit complet et
qu'on arrive aux 35 milles c'est écrit à
il faut bien aller enfin guéri par
contre ouais maxime il est très très bon
la danse est dans ce passage là là il va
essayer de jouer des coups précis pour
garder l'attention
j'étais bien dire il ay sûr il vous
parlera temps je m en grande calmes
parce qu'il survient également alors
pour g6 qu'est ce qu'on fait là un petit
coup d'un f2p sont là dan de l'epide
bouger elle a remis la veille à un
frisson la irie nom maxime aie confiance
et bien c'est ça vous marque s'était
confiée en quoi voit les bouges nous
notre dame m'a dit on voit les gros coup
la dame f 2 h 3 fait nous un blocus km2
il doit non de toute façon cette dame en
h4
elle est moche elle peut penser avoir
choisi joueur ou un chien ouais bon roi
jean ça va aussi à la gare ou un chat 4
le droit chemin de sa part c'est pas
flagrant que ça va je calcule l'ouest on
va chez 1,4 puis on prend pour 8,5 sur
la tronche après mais c'est double
tranchant la bannière metro choix n'est
pas plaisir non c'est mieux dehors des
deux camps du coup oui oui non bien sûr
je ne sais pas ce pape est foutu du tout
quoi que tout peut arriver on propose
d'avoir est le problème c'est qu'ils
arrivent tremblay remparts ou h1 parce
qu'il se mettra pas à ce qu'on fout en
face du vis-à-vis la messe de regards
guerrière elle arrive de cité sur le max
de jouer
du coup il faut qu'on ramène de tous
rangs en 8,8 à tam alors dit bonsoir
transit de merde me proposer vraiment on
n'est pas ici pour sa tour 8 le coup
j'aurais fait humainement leucate ff5
c'est la règle bah oui c'est ça c'est
beau quand même 4 puis on prend un f5
ciblant beau fixe on voit pas quel point
ça marche en l'avenir ou qui a alors dit
mais où il s'était dit la tante bonjour
positionnant environ mais toujours vu de
mr g
en fait le truc tour huit tours 1 2 4
puis on prend un f5 et du coup là il
faut vite replacé cette tour c4 sur la
troisième rangée pour bloquer cette tour
j'ai donc tour ces trois tours j'ai trop
longs kayalar aucun souci pour la
position blanche si on peut garder le
ménage crois qu'en fera nul voilà je
pense pas qu'on puisse la gagner parce
que je
en fait j'en ai pas mal en pratique et
je me sentais de gagner que les blancs
genre truc et puis tant fait rêver la
tech dame fou c'est hyper dur en fait
votre le roy hill un peuple est tout
seul c'est très bizarre
tarifs 1 mais là je sens qu'il ya une
paire de tours du but j'ai trois pions
non ça c'est quoi tu veux quoi tout re
1,4
je comprends tout reprendre battus à
regarder sur on tourne pas tu peux avoir
la partage sur le hockey ah oui comme ça
ok je vous dis fini par être obligé de
faire tant g3 et c'est mieux il a joué
gros gibier toi ça pas très logique
mais bon ça ne suffit pas pour le coup
mais de très bonne qualité des
explications de base ont tous regagné
latifah mais maxime il a peut-être
laissé passer sa chance quand même aller
nous a fait un ouais ouais bah oui là si
ça pouvait mieux de jeu heureusement
mallet le h6 qui était assez étonnant de
la part de guy et après max qui a pas
été assez précis
dif compliqué et peu après s'il va jouer
quatre c'est pas sûr maxime blanchet pas
sur toi là quand même vraiment après te
prendre 4 de passe rien la question
c'est ce que eric ailleurs il ajoute
aura un ace que qui aura le courage de
jouer quatre web on fait le 4e jeu f5
die
allez on peut se dire que là il peut
jouer il rit peut très bien jouer une
sorte de de coude à temps il voit pas il
peut jouer aussi f5
mais f54 du coup tu bloques f5
tu sais ce que tu peux faire tu peux que
tu puisses 23 ans damien trois ou quatre
4 ans à peine la téméraire que très bien
joué f5 jerry west
il adore est en contrôle complet ouais
vas jouer de façon naïve à jouer ils
hésitent
le jeu tour eux aussi ceci pour ramener
aura aussi pour 13,6 peut-être oui il
peut faire mais aux 4,7 go qui je
préfère c'est le plus beau c'est plus
chic et 1
mais malgré tout quelques trente
secondes c'est chaud mais bon il est
fort avec ce prix je veux car je l
attends je vais très bien myiow et ben
du coup ça veut dire qu'il a vraiment
progressé parce que ces genres de
position où avant ils n'étaient pas
forcément capables de faire de tel
enchaînement guéri
donc la fremm c'est sûr qui comprend f5
nous demande d'amm prend mais adam
préemption prend et à un tour prend au f
2 on attaque à deux tours les deux tours
à temps c'est quoi ça si on prend f5
dame prend bien de manger 2 dans l'autre
sens c'est du coup ouais c'est assez
joli 11 août je sais non mais pourquoi
je devrais fin de la fuite
même s'il faut prendre quatre dom
prendre 17.4 on lève 5 c c'est hyper
chaud non 4 attend maso le tangible at
il est bizarre on sait quelle grosse
erreur à tanger cat
ok quand j'étais alors juste bizarre à
temps je peux empêcher le double échange
des tours
de toute façon il faut je vais dalle ces
deux du power aide non ouais vous pouvez
tourner des 4 vallées qu'il avait
progressé publié par s'échapper tout de
suite f5 c'est juste la suite allé les
voir dit son type en avantage tout de
suite énorme avantage ff5 bkp génitaux
pour prendre quatre des torrents
français 74.4 ses 600 m en 20 jou le
deuil ses deux couettes de monsieur je
crois que la vie est tellement logique
en tant qu'unité fanton fut non plus
d'âme c'est du temps à tan tan et
touchera d'amis touche à l'âme alors
peut-être qu'il va y va je pense à mon
garçon juste assez bien en au 36e il
reste pas énormément de temps pour se
ressaisir
allez maxime alors peut-être mc2 c'est
monstrueux c'est dame séduit les quais
simon gagne en quoi à deux doigts adams
et de six paires fin de la vie d'un seul
coup tu dois je le fous b5 mais ça va
pas du tout alors retrouvé 5 il ne
jouera jamais c'est impossible mais 5h
troyes et tours g4 c'est incroyable ce
coup droit joué parfaitement il nous a
fait une série depuis dame des sept îles
et je 1 et jeudi coup parfait trop la
mecque qu'est-ce qu'on vivrait mon
garçon il apprend raison de toi non à la
safer d'échanger tous deux allés plus de
tours et plus rien finie la cellule tout
de suite où le roi au la déception stage
les ascenseurs émotionnels
c'est quand même un gros choc un maxime
sur salaire est si terrible
mesdames ces deux cités rideau c'était
un bon feeling et comment il a raté ses
sais pas
va tomber car peut-être le coup le pnb 4
ses fils et ses fabriques à droite c'est
pas si simple mais bon c'est pas si loin
non plus ouais ça se plaint et noyon
mettre le fond ces six b5 et puis
passent leur tour avec encore à six
points d'avancé rien on est d'accord
c'est la déroute à dalle
voilà là elle a manqué une munition pour
la cité c'est un coup quoi on était sûr
qu'il ait joué même si lyon bat et les
papas dans un premier temps il n'était
pas parti sur dame ces deux quand même
je suis pas médecin mais je sais pas
trop mais bon s'il le perd sur des
pseudos il a dû le voir
tu peux pas revenir en arrière après les
jeux tu leur as tu seras tu là mais
l'art des fous mais qu'attend m comme
ces deux f-16 va plus dans un sacré bon
je sais bien tout ce qui s'est dit mais
ses actes et limin la dame d'un âge d'or
la même dame sait si c'est très bien 4
comprend 401 truc qu'est ce qui pousse
le public est content et je la tour à
tour un ouais c'est cet abandon
ces deux pour prendre 17,5 des fous
machin faut prendre quatre tours 7
c'est très beau ben c'est que tu prends
les dames et tapas la tour est en l'air
du couteau
non c'est pas si simple mais
peut-être savais pas trop ce qui s'est
dit [ __ ] j'ai raté bon je sais pas
c'est douloureux mais en fait c'est
bizarre ce qui en fait depuis
depuis qu'il a joué des six là il ya
disparu ouais en fait c'est la
continuité adams et 2,6 l'arrivée je
peux pas dire à coup de bol parce que je
l'adoré mais ce n'était pas dans la
continuité de ce qu'il faisait depuis
depuis le début ouais ouais là il a eu
un petit moment d'absence une nouvelle
fois un peu comme contre caruana cette
partie finalement dans un scénario où il
joue assez bien sorti tout verture ai vu
des bons coups et tout d'un coup il ya
une absence est nommé partie est très
bizarre en fait fait il a joué des coups
normaux il faut même pas dire bon tu te
développe geek fâche si tu prends des
décisions vers l'arrière et après
après ça switch d'iris moi je veux des
coups normaux
ouais mais ses coups de génie non plus
et maxime ça va pas du coup la bonne
nouvelle c'est que sacha va gagner et
variolink envoyé au lean contexte ça
c'est bon c'est la bonne nouvelle
si on peut dire caruana souffre même pas
non voilà c'est un peu l'inversé d'hier
en fait hier ça se passait très mal ça a
bien fini là ça pouvait cyr très bien et
ça c'est fini on aura les et guiry
défendre il ya même pas de défense n'ont
rien à faire un f6 et touche ton en vain
mais mes pions en a 500 n'est pas bondée
d'hommes projet de vote
radanne c2c le fini quoi damas à thème
continuent d'abonder cette chute peut
les changer on va te vois tu peut les
changer tu fais pousser 6 donc bref un
jardin mais ça ne fait rien on a eu ces
mots sionnel h3 terrible ils ont fait
nul
bon après écoute avant la partie nulle
on disait que c'était pas si mal mais
c'est dommage mais le scénario
non c'est pas si mal surtout que caruana
gagne pas c'est quand même aussi une
bonne nouvelle est née bon là non
s'attendent à ce qu'ils gagnent donc
maxime non non en fait il est entre
mario attendu mais il y en aurait pu
avoir une embellie du scénario et voilà
avant la rencontre elles ont tous dit
c'est ces résultats-là bon c'est normal
vu la partie quoi ah non ça va encore
maso il reste quatre parties il a deux
mains et bien sûr et là c'est un gros
une grosse opportunité dans la tête oui
c'est plus après cette partie c'est dur
on cas il va bien se reposer puis va
revenir pour pour vendredi
après green shoe que ça peut être
l'embellie assez importants comme
partout avec les normes est très
important puisque grisou qui va envoyer
de toute façon illégale il va envoyer
aux lignes s'en fout du compte il y
croit du tout qui se sont une hausse de
faire quatre sur quatre non mais c'est
pas qu'il y croit ou pas c'est quand
même ça change toute façon je suis là
bon j'en vois mieux à chaque fois puis
fut pas hésité j'ai une chance sur cinq
à chaque fois 5 x 5 25 x 5 125 x 5 800
ans à milan j'ai une chance sur cent il
ya un candidat enfin je m'en fous fin
non mais tu joues bien mais tu vois je
tu prends ta chance sur 1 800 et puis ça
passe ça va ça passe pas avant
on s'en fout ici 125 peu importe mais je
sais pas c'est une chance sur cinq à
chaque fois je pensais plus sur
certaines plus de 2 g ça avec les noirs
je pense que c'est plus qu'une chance
sur 1 800 ça est une chance sur mille
quatre cent mille cinq cents mais bon
est-ce que tu t'en fous en fait tu la
prend au crack inhabituel faut pas que
ça se termine trop vite j'ai rien faire
au corps a je pense ça va se finir assez
assez vite en vrille
alors est ce qu'il va faire nul tempo
est ce que je pense pas un gorille plus
à tourner longtemps nous fait comme hier
sacha on peut aller voir la famille ait
note peut-être je sais que j'ai mis
ouais j'ai mis ça met du coup
l'échiquier voilà au coeur qui m'a dit
sg patients classe tu va avec
ouais je peux rester cinq minutes donc
en moi ce soir vous faire des sushis
c'est pas trop tard non on peut aller
chercher la bonne nouvelle quand même là
le plateau de sushis va partir bon j'en
ferais mieux que sacha gagne quoi pour
qu'ils aient encore une chance qui fait
un pas complètement la porte à max je
pense que s'il fait nul ou qu'ils
perdent wave ou plus pour rien il va
commencer à justin d'échangés surtout
que maxime il peut vraiment le battre
avec les noirs a déjà fait d'ailleurs
que c'est un joueur qui peut bien lui
convenir dans ce cas de figure critique
en contre
le spécial n'a pas vu que saddam était
attaquée quand même savoir quand il la
donne et adam en fait ok le cinquième
partie assez la grâce à des pages a4
elle devait pas prendre des cinq je
pense et a complètement foutu le spécial
non là bas ça doit bien sûr les gens
temps comme son ombre au fort après le
truc aussi négatif que j'étais en train
de penser c'est guéri encore en piste
aux siens ah oui mais c'est pas grave
très grave en fait j'ai pas idiot sorti
une défense de fou dans une finale je
sais pas les cons l'idée quand il est
moins bien ça joue pendant six heures
les mecs qui met une pression de ouf et
lui fera rater très vite là je crois que
malheureusement le fait d'avoir joué 13
heures en deux jours a peut-être eu un
petit impact
après c'est très dur quand la nba quand
le mec que je joue toujours aussi ce
projet si tu sais que tu commence à
perdre le fil
h3 tu vois nul était hyper contents ils
n'ont rien d'une dame c'est lui c'est
pas si grave que par oui c'est un coup
de bol mais bon ça va jusqu'à la
conception avec damas quatre matches
quatre lots il va s'en vouloir
mc2 bon voilà c'est un miracle ça arrive
parfois oui comme un gars ils étaient
pas construire
partir à l'assaut de zain vingtaine de
minutes chacun prend vraiment très très
bien pour les normes nm de plus mais bon
t'as dis qu'est-ce qui rôde et toujours
des fous d icade maîtresse et voilà ça
passe pas mais bon qui sait que
j'utilise guéri un dépôt la prochaine je
n'ai aucun regret par un jus qu'à roanne
avec les blancs d'affaires du groupe est
la série la vie s'appelle awanga au noir
je peux dresser des ailes blanches
je pense y fait que des nuls n'est pas
rare pour faire 4 je veux faire que des
nuls il a battu mais qu'il devait battre
ici et là si c'est le plan classique
avec deux gains et deux nuls ex-aequo
hockey et caruana et guérison et c'est
arrivé aussi et ont tous cessé d'arriver
à + + 2 serait guéri ses coûts on
n'allait pas +3 la presse et +3 et on
essaie de faire plus 3 qu'il aille
chercher dîner avec les blancs jeu après
prendre kirill à la dernière avec les
blancs gris mauve et blanc et caruana
voir quel point le stationnement car on
en a nommé pour reprendre 7 euros soit
2,4
c'est nul ça leur évite à voir mais ceux
qui trouvent qu'il est pro g7 encore
trop j'espère reprendre sa croissance
tournait un peu la tronche la fin non
non c'est loin d'être fini là on se
méfie après il y avait une chance une
vraie chance aujourd'hui de se remettre
hyper bien en selle mais disons il
tourne enfin
statu quo en fait le rapport à avant la
partie donc il a gagné à oui oui mais
bon je pense qu'on verra
ouais ok faut le faire mais n'est pas
écrit écrit qui est quand même un petit
rappel une mauvaise journée du 26 mai a
quand même les blancs et on espère et
qui a une petite chance d'adoption
sochaux 20 secondes d'attention
bon les gars je vous fais la bise merci
sève et à très vite 25,1 donc demain
jour de repos ça va faire du bien
ouais
la fin ou parce qu'ils pensent que oui
monsieur vous prend des cinq toute la
période où j'ai exagéré 5-fu des quatre
thuluth soft et pias quoi tu prends un
but est de bonne foi c'est joli c'est
une belle variante attend sur un peu
quoi c'est bizarre composition des six
qui t'arrive t ie 7 10 secondes à la
pendule à le spécial est vraiment
spéciale il doit faire maintenant tu
peux faire d'autre
donc une idée fab
alors
et donc là il doit trouver tout reprend
touré cavalier s'en va pour attaquer la
dame et pour défendre la cause des
quatre pour le fou ce qui est pas facile
a dit fait ouais
attend il fait le tour prend pour le
moment mais bon puisque faire tu prends
200 tu peux juste atteint l'âge fait
refouler 4 avant ce taux est le vrai
c'est peut-être le plus efficace kf5
quoi est de toute façon tu leur as quand
tu veux c'est chaud hein
c'est très chaud la position sympa on va
jouer pour gagner le tournoi mais on ne
vaut moins c'est intéressant ce qui se
passera allez on va voir celle des deux
mondes
il y avait cinq secondes au moment de
jouer donc et peut-être de défense
d'avocate faudra te faire dame prend fou
et quelques conseils à 31 points de
moins mais presque si du coup critique
doit pas gagner sur qui va fermer la
porte contre maxime devoir vous devriez
peut-être juste s'en fout complètement m
lapeyre dont sais pas en fait
mais si en psychologie commence à lui
faire mal ne peut pas gagner aujourd'hui
nous sommes de plus
la dame à [ __ ] des gars d'avoir plus
précis parce que justement tu es chef
direct j'ai fait une bonne salade coup
là le spécial web à ce que disait malade
peut très bien jouer bon je le fous et
c'est tendu tu as des six étages dessus
et ça ne donnait un soutien pour lequel
valiquette mettre échec est un peu dans
les cornes quoi ces cinq plus raté une
âme était très très bas alors ce que je
pensais que c'était ça l'idée gritche
opus super nul chose dh 6 rage cette
équipe rivaux batman
ouais
qui est dans le dur mais bon golf et
surtout ses bêtes qu'ils pensent de base
qu'il aucune chance de gagner le truc
parce que enfin ils vont pas si mal
non mais il rate détruits je n'ai jamais
déjà mais ils essayent enfin je veux
dire quelques rats l'ouvragé
enfin pas de critiques à faire juste un
mois rend compte quand tu as tu peux
plus tu limite la casse souvent mais
s'ils se sont envoyé comme chronique
avait fait la dernière fois bien les
parties agréable à regarder
tu te fais plaisir toi même elle reste
plus que six coups à jouer après celle
raju a peut-être dur des 6 mai
ouais c'est compliqué nous serions
passés il est super bien protégé le roi
blanc et en sécurité souvent il faut
attaquer le roc dames de plus c'est
l'inversé qui se passe
les blancs plein de pièces qui
tournicotent autour du roi noir choquer
mais chaud et de l'autre côté par
curiosité
ok ça ce liquide
il ya peut-être même plus davantage pour
les noirs le petit fou comme ça
peut-être qu'on voit là nul on sait qu'à
roanne avec les blancs contre contre
ding photos des joueurs sur le côté donc
voilà on va peut-être la nuit en direct
car on n'a aucun intérêt pour faire au
f-16 que faire d'autre
surtout que c'est la ccry tous et ça en
fait remarquer sur wii
une nouvelle rangée de la preuve
bon ça devrait faire nul on vous tiendra
au courant
wang hao sajoo s'approche du roi c'est
très dur souffle au nord encore
trois-quatre quoi défendre parce que
tend vers 8h 17h premier set
ouais mais bon puisque tu vas y arriver
je dois pas te faire un tour aussi sa
maman système f7 apprennent on l'a déjà
une star prend 2,6 non je pense que nul
fait tranquille en fait non ça va pour
great choc bordeaux 30 jours n'est pas
trop long aujourd'hui on va vous ces
trois tours prendre ici c'est trop
distante
je pense c'est ce qui va se passer
fallait attendre déçu souffert malgré
tout qu'est ce que tu crois qu'il veut
comme on peut pour fou peut-être multi
nishikawa nul c'est chez caruana et donc
il restait plus qu'une
ça pourrait finir plus tôt fab te cache
pas que je ne serai pas mécontent non
sauf une petite journée tranquille on a
tous les jours on their 23h05 commence
dans le pré live avant de faire
l'honneur icap est tous assez choc
terrible
non
là ça va faire mieux je vais créer un
corps en étoiles ans les analyses mais
il est issu il n'a rien de prêt après
s'il ya besoin que on meuble un moment
pour toute analyse semble estrimont
meublant mais bon pas être quatre ans
même après la halle avantage c'est que
je peux peut-être le faire sur cet ordi
du coup si on doit meubler et on fera la
vidéo après comme c'est un peu comme il
est plus tôt que d'habitude
stream sikia immeuble exact d'armes et
ballon c'est un petit récap entre nous
gentillet comme je vous fais les autres
jours d'habitude rapides ont certes on
est parti en parler un peu de ce
shooting tout ça et après ses excuses
pour ces deux variantes avec les
nouveautés les lignes d'ordi les trucs
et sert à quoi
philippaerts a quand même il faut il
faut faire plaisir à dany ranch pas
d'après peut la jouer
athènes
buse les blancs mettre le pion à 3 dont
on ne peut plus jamais cassé l'édifice
avec a5b 4 et puis l'autre côté du
ranger que quoi quoi faire la seule
chance de bien méchant normalement ça
fait enfin c'est un peu comme la partie
de mpl contre guéri ça tu peux jouer une
heure comme joe une minute sachant vers
un site en a un des deux qui veut jouer
une heure il joue une heure vraiment
fait je fais me payer ni à 2 je me dis
même continué de ja tour dès septembre
en baisse est donc en fait t'as pas tant
à faire on en est là c'est vraiment nul
de chez nul à la tour tu vas faire à
trois tours f4 tourache 4ème but lors
des quatre journées en moi j'ai six
bombes à trois jours avec les blancs
pour et surtout bien mettre en place une
fois que ces options est là le fou
défense pions le pion des champions tout
est défendu la tourelle fait barrage au
roi ici et bal adam peut venir balades
et des échecs balleroy d'affaires ça ça
ça joue assez vite lissage un lot de
bien sûr voilà c'est visible que tu peux
plus rien faire ni d'un côté ni le nom
ça doit faire nul à bath nuls et voit la
fin de la journée
fin de la journée un courte journée
finalement favori sera jouée quatre
heures 4h ben écoute 24 heures
exactement alors bilan de la journée un
peu déçu par maxime ce que lui sa chance
ne pourra pas tremblé du tout il a
explosé complètement sans combattre et
avec cenco donc mais peu accentue son
avance au classement après avec thank
you dijon patrick cenco c'est
normalement le plan donc c'est pour ça
qu'il ya une catastrophique en soi parce
que c'était prévisible pour un joueur de
la classe de nespouls avec les blancs
contre lui après faut-il encore le faire
chaque fois qu'il aura et noir qui
perdra avec 5 go mais voilà
et caro nadine guillet nul mais caranobe
pas arrivé à trop pousser même c'est lui
qui a souffert un peu donc ce qui se
passe avec bane et pau reprendre dix
points de plus au classement donc là un
point entier d' avance sur maxime sur
guy et sur caruana donc en gros rien
n'est fait mais clairement dans la
deuxième moitié de tournoi maxime fort
qui gagne au moins deux parties et voilà
est la même en fait on peut dire pour
guéri et caruana en fait ils sont tout
simplement cette situation là s'ils font
pas donc 3 sur 4 je pense qu'ils
reverront pas n'importe quoi si ce qui
m'appartient
[Applaudissements]
après l'effort non
le front de presse langues
[Applaudissements]
il ya tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le tout
petit frère cette somme
naji six corps
c
dante enjoy
[Musique]
notre équipe qui ne sait pas
pour les amis il doit avoir une autre
conférence de presse à qui va commencer
je passe il ya qui fait ou pas nous on
attend ce jour quand on est au crédoc
issue je pense que derrière la dernière
celle de gris tchouk on mais c'est un
petit peu en attendant et après après on
récupérera on récupère cas quand eto'o
je vous lirai add qu'on fait le switch
que cornetto bien non
belle son vrai nom peut pas entendre on
les voit on voit qu'ils bougent les
pièces ils sont très heureux mais on
sait pas ce qu'ils disent qu on ne sait
pas
gi joe
m
[Musique]
limoges que synchrone en sommes sûrs que
la spéciale
désappointement or not okay de hockey
news de noms que vous ne baissez les
mêmes aux fans de queen du tout iron
news is me batte à coût neutre même vol
crown de tout mais ouanna au château
find that because it's like white s'est
apaisé les âmes des choses des juifs
yéménites au finish qu'ils devaient
locmane civique les bêtes sauvages need
to prevent the secret circle city for
only considering that is for this is
back fabrique du fort d'issy tchèque
green design pour newton tech japonais
mostoles les niveaux de cash active note
au restaurant
shosanna start tout calculé qu'une
guérite où j'étais night for green day
for loving you to i want to the noah 13
rue du fort net doublait à chicago
ok queen du five à covenant top 6 et 6
et jesse hughes screen du tout maxime
potvin les gars on va pouvoir faire leur
ai dit d'accord on est au pied près a du
coup pas comme d'habitude je vous
attendais à quelques secondes ça à
partir pour les analystes c'est à partir
pour les analyses
si vous voulez suivre la fin de la
conférence de presse d'autres choses
comme un discours tout court et si vous
voulez suivre les alizé cornet ont fait
on fait le petit raid
merci merci à vous les amis d'avoir
suivi on se retrouve demain
merci j'adore